vous êtes armé bien d'écouter mes chers
collègues mais à messieurs nous allons
continuer nos travaux et je suis ravi
d'accueillir jean marc jancovici qui est
ingénieur conseil en énergie climat
vous avez été sollicité pour être
auditionné dans cette commission
denquête qui traite du coût de l'énergie
du prix d'électricité
c'était une demande qui avait été fait
par le groupe écologie du sénat le
bureau a accepté cette demande
doucette d'où cette commission denquête
alors je vais vous demander parce que
c'est une règle important dans une
commission des requêtes
je vais vous demander de prêter serment
c'est à dire de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité
je vous demandais de lever la main
droite et de dire je le jure je le jure
eh bien je m'en réjouis et vous avez
reçu à l'avance de manière à permettre
d'avancer dans nos travaux un
questionnaire de la part de notre
rapporteur tout c'est lui qui a le goût
des versions non plus pas reçue ça je
n'en changerai pas mais c'est pas très
grave parce que de toute façon ce que
j'ai l'intention de vous dire est assez
c'est comme en politique c'est assez
indépendant de la question ah bon on va
quand même vous demander un petit peu
dans le sujet écoutez en fait je vais
comme un but donnait avoua luisa tamayo
il va vous rappeler un petit peu les six
questions qu'il avait l'intention de
vous poser et puis vous y répondre et en
totalité partiellement
et puis si vous si nous manquons
d'informations nous vous posons des
questions complémentaires si vous le
voulez bien
monsieur rapporteur avoue oui bien
monsieur jean marc jancovici donc désolé
à ne pas que les questions
y'a comme les ayez pas reçu mais la
première question mais je pense que vous
allez dans le sujet comment année
analysez-vous le ressent rapport de la
cour des comptes sous le sur le coût de
l'électricité nucléaire
d'accord êtes vous favorable notamment
pour ce qui concerne le coût de
l'électricité à la prolongation de durée
de vie des centrales nucléaires ou au
développement d'une nouvelle génération
de centrales p r ou quatrième génération
ou un développement des énergies
renouvelables
de manière générale les tarifs actuels
d'électricité vous paraît style réfléter
refléter dit fidèlement le coût réel
d'électricité c'est même tarif ou
semble-t-il pertinent d'un point de vue
environnemental pour regarder message
envoyé aux consommateurs quel jugement
portez-vous filière par filière sur le
mécanisme actuel de soutien aux
différentes énergies renouvelables et à
la cogénération le prix et dernière
question le prix de l'électricité en
europe devraient ils mieux refléter le
coût des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre la prochaine acquisition à titre
onéreux des dicota par les électriciens
va-t-elle dans le bon sens ou
aura-t-elle des conséquences et
aura-t-elle des conséquences sur le prix
payé par les consommateurs
quant à leur vestiaire je ne sens pas à
des années lumière de ce que vous aviez
prévu de nous dire ce sujet vous le
saviez quand même à vous la parole
d'accord quel est le créneau de temps
dont on dispose art ou aux humeurs 1h15
où vous avez dakar 45 minutes au maximum
présenté c'est du temps pour les
questions d'accord alors si vous voulez
pas attraper un torticolis
les images sont juste derrière et
pendant que vous vous déplacez en fait
la réponse aux questions vous m'avez
posé peut tenir en très peu de mots à
partir du moment où on partage les
présupposés que je vais essayer de vous
montrer maintenant donc dit autrement
c'est la partie que je vais essayer de
vous exposer maintenant qui assoient les
réponses aux questions que je vais vous
faire qu'ils ont assez vite
ensuite en fait l'essentiel de mon
exposé va viser à rappeler quelque chose
de très simple qui est que avant d'être
un avant de se réfléter dans un prix
payé par le consommateur avant de se
refléter dans quoi que ce soit qu'on
puisse imputer comme vice ou comme
vertus aux différentes énergies dont on
dispose
l'énergie c'est une grandeur en physique
l'énergie c'est par définition en
physique la grandeur qui caractérise le
changement d'état d'un système alors je
voudrais faire ce petit rappel parce que
dire que l'énergie est une grandeur
physique
c'est dire qu'elle obéit à un certain
nombre de lois et je soutiens comme un
certain nombre de gens que les faits
scientifiques ne sont pas des opinions
série s'impose à nous et que si on
essaye de construire l'avenir en
ignorant les faits scientifiques tout ce
qu'on fait c'est d'être dans le mur donc
je vais essayer de vous rappeler
quelques éléments de base sur l'énergie
dont je vous le disais c'est par
définition ce qui caractérise le
changement alors on le voit bien du
point de vue de l'utilisateur
un certain nombre de choses qui
aujourd'hui sont passés dans la vie
courante mais c'est très récent dans
l'histoire des hommes suppose d'utiliser
ou de restituer l'énergie alors c'est le
cas par exemple si vous modifiez une
température dans une pièce ça va
consommer ou restituer l'énergie
si vous mettez un objet en mouvement ou
si vous l'arrêter ça va
il va y avoir d'énergie qui va
intervenir dans cette histoire si vous
changez une forme
vous avez de l'énergie qui intervient et
aujourd'hui tous les ouvriers des usines
sont devenus essentiellement des gens
qui appuient sur des boutons et des
manettes pour piloter des machines qui
vont modifier changer des formes et
extrudés ex filer aplatir en bout tir et
c'est donc l'ouvrier moderne il est il
utilise pas plus ses muscles que
l'employé des services il appuie sur des
boutons et des manettes on utilise de
l'énergie quand on modifie une
composition chimique
c'est du reste celle que notre organisme
a utilisé en premier pour qu'on ait des
muscles et qu'on puisse se mouvoir
quand vous avez un corps qui se déplace
dans un champ avec lequel il interagit
vous avez de l'énergie qui intervient
quand une composition atomique change
vous avez de l'énergie qui intervient et
soit dit en passant toutes les énergies
qu'on utilise sur terre sont des dérivés
directe ou indirecte de l'énergie
nucléaire et enfin vous avez de
l'énergie qui intervient quand de la
matière et du rayonnement interagissent
ton dire qu'on utilise de l'énergie ou
dire qu'on change le monde qui nous
entoure c'est pareil c'est exactement
pareil
et de là soit dit en passant vous avez
une conclusion simple qui est que
l'énergie propre
tu pas puisque par définition utiliser
de l'énergie s'est changée ce qui nous
entoure et ça ne peut pas être propre
savait être propre et laisser les lieux
dans l'état dans lequel vous les avez
trouvés et quand on utilise de l'énergie
c'est justement pour faire l'inversé
donc l'énergie propre ça peut pas
exister ce qui peut exister c'est une
énergie dont les bénéfices sont
significativement plus important que les
inconvénients ou d'anvers mais une
énergie propre ça n'existe pas c'est
juste une affaire de chiffre comme c'est
une grandeur physique c'est juste une
affaire de chiffre tout ça ce qui a fait
la totalité du monde qui nous entoure
aujourd'hui c'est ce que je vais vous
exposer mais c'est le petit calcul
d'ordre de grandeur que je vais vous
exposer maintenant donc je soutiens que
ce qui a fait les 35 heures l'égalité
homme-femme le divorce les études
longues
la tertiarisation de l'économie
l'étalement urbain la concentration
urbaine les campagnes qui se vide etc
c'est juste ce que je vais vous
expliquer maintenant lorsque je vais
vous expliquer maintenant c'est la
comparaison entre l'énergie qui est
capable de fournir vos muscles ou les
miens et l'énergie qui est associé à
toutes les machines que nous utilisons y
compris le vidéoprojecteur qui est en
train d'être utilisé en ce moment
l'ordinateur dont je me sers le métro
qui m'a amené ici la machine qui vous a
fait le café etc
alors si je prends mon organisme humain
et que je prends quelqu'un de bien
entrer des donc je prends un militaires
du pghm et je le fais monter sur le mont
blanc chaud ce qui fait tous les matins
pour se mettre en appétit et bien simon
militaire pèse 65 kg il aura restituer
dans cet exercice de l'ordre d'un demi
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
alors je sais pas qui d'entre vous est
déjà monté sur le mont blanc d'une
journée moi je les fais mais en deux
jours donc je peux vous dire que ce
genre d'effort c'est assez significatif
et si vous faites ça le lundi vous le
faites pas le mardi le mercredi le jeudi
le vendredi le samedi le dimanche et on
recommence la semaine d'après donc vous
prenez un organisme humain le maximum
maximorum de ce qu'il est capable de
fournir avec ses jambes qui sont les
muscles les plus puissants de notre
organisme en une journée c'est une
fraction kilowattheure fraction
kilowattheures par journée de travail
admettons que je ne sois pas un
esclavagiste mais quelqu'un qui paye
correctement ses employés et bien en
payant cette personne au smic donc je
l'install sur un pédalier dans une usine
je la fait pédaler comme un forcené pour
fournir de l'énergie je la paye au smic
eh bien je vais payer mon kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique de l'ordre de
quelques centaines d'euros
quelques centaines d'euros quand bien
même je ne respecterai aucune des lois
sociales en vigueur dans ce pays et que
j'avais ferait appel à d
l'avs le simple fait de devoir les
maintenir en vie les nourrir les
protéger du froid des prédateurs et ces
m'amènerait encore mon kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique à quelques heures ou
quelques dizaines d'euros et vous verrez
la comparaison tout à l'heure avec
l'énergie des machines et vous
comprendrez pourquoi l'esclavagisme a
disparu si maintenant je fais appel à
quelqu'un qui utilise ses bras en gros
je suis un facteur 10 en dessous donc
c'est en ce qui concerne la quantité
d'énergie restituer et donc je suis un
facteur 10 au dessus en ce qui concerne
le prix que je vais payer mon énergie
mécanique
si je me prends maintenant notre très
chère essence qui en ce moment à fall
temps les foules et bien un litre
d'essence contient de l'ordre de 10
kilowatts heure d'énergie chimique
une fois que je fais passer ça dans un
moteur j'ai quelques kilowatts heure
d'énergie mécanique ce qui veut dire
qu'en coût marginal ou là j'ai pas mis
le coup du moteur le kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique issue d'une machine
va coûter 1000 à 10000 fois moins cher
que le coût du travail de quelqu'un payé
au smic alors une fois je vous ai dit ça
je vous ai dit que n'importe quel
différentiel de salaire dans le monde se
compensent par n'importe quel trajet je
vous ai dit qu'en mettant des machines à
notre service on a multiplié notre
pouvoir d'achat par 50 cent mille voilà
je vous ai tout dit tout absolument tout
tout ce qui fait les acquis sociaux
réside là dedans tout alors vous verrez
après que ça quelques implications alors
la première que ça a c'est que
contrairement à une idée couramment
répandue le prix réel de l'énergie
depuis qu'on en utilise n'a pas augmenté
il a considérablement décru qu'est ce
que le prix réel
c'est le temps que vous devez travailler
pour vous payer un kilowattheure la
seule chose qui n'a pas varié depuis mes
arrière arrière arrière arrière grands
parents c'est une fête qui 24 heures par
jour est donc la seule chose
incompressibles la seule unité constante
dans le temps
pardon cette répétition pour mesurer le
prix réel de quelque chose c'est le camp
que je dois travailler pour l'acquérir
tout le temps que je dois consacrer à
son acquisition toute autre unité
monétaire est trompeuse et en
particulier le prix en monnaie courante
et même le prix en monnaie constante
parce qu'il faut ramener ça à ce que les
gens gagnent et si la fiche de paye
augmentent plus vite que le prix en
mains des constantes
le prix réel n'a pas du tout augmente et
il a baissé ici vous avez le prix du
pétrole qui a été le prix directeur de
toutes les autres énergies et qui leur
est encore pendant très longtemps donc
depuis 1860
et vous voyez comment des constantes le
prix du baril de pétrole entre 1881 là
ils étaient concurrents de l'huile de
baleine donc il a aussi la décrue à peu
près comme le prix l'huile de baleine
entre 1880 et 1970 le prix du baril de
pétrole est resté relativement stable
aux alentours de 20 dollars en monnaie
constante pendant que dans le même temps
la fiche de paye du consommateur
occidental était multiplié par 15 à 20
ça revient à dire que le prix du litre
de pétrole en termes réels a été divisée
par 15 à 20 et comme dans le même temps
ma corporation celle des ingénieurs a
remarquablement travaillé et à augmenter
l'efficacité mécanique de l'utilisation
d'un litre de pétrole d'un de n'importe
quoi entre un facteur 2 et 10 ça veut
dire que mon esclave énergétique la dont
je parlais tout à l'heure c'est à dire
la machine qui travaillent à ma place eh
bien le coût réel de mon kilowattheure
issus de mon esclave énergétique a été
divisée par n'importe quoi entre 50 et
100 en l'espace d'un siècle maintenant
si vous prenez le prix de n'importe quel
objet qu'on peut acquérir aujourd'hui
une table une chaise une paire de
lunettes une chemise etc et qui existait
déjà il ya un siècle
vous vous rendrez compte que son prix
réel c'est-à-dire exprimé en tant de
travail a été divisé par un facteur 50 à
100 c'est ça l'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat
c'est très exactement ça l'augmentation
du pouvoir d'achat donc l'augmentation
du pouvoir d'achat peut sera mené en
première approximation à la baisse du
prix réel de l'énergie je dis bien en
première approximation même sur des
périodes récentes contrairement à l'idée
qu'on s'en fait le prix de l'énergie
continuent de baisser alors vous avez
ici un très beau graphique issu d'un
très beau service d'un très beau
ministère français qui est le sos et qui
vous donne donc le service de
l'observation et des statistiques ne
sais pas si il prête serment mais ils
font de très bonnes statistiques et vous
avez ici pour commencer les budgets
carburant et électricité gaz et autres
combustibles des français depuis 1970 a
envoyé six ans il gère le budget ça
monte
bon je me dis bon balle est donc les
gens payent de plus en plus cher en fait
le truc important c'est ça c'est à dire
la part dans le budget des ménages dit
autrement dit autrement le temps de
travail qu'il faut consacrer à acheter
son énergie et là vous voyez qu'on a une
évolution qui est l'exact inverse et que
l'énergie coûte aujourd'hui moins cher
qu'avant le premier choc pétrolier moins
cher qu'avant le premier choc pétrolier
donc contrairement encore une fois à une
idée couramment répandue et ça ça
appuiera une partie des réponses que je
vais vous faire un peu plus tard
l'énergie ne vaut pas de plus en plus
cher elle vaut de moins en moins chers
en fait elle est passée de rien a encore
moins quand je vous disais tout à
l'heure que l'énergie mécanique vaut un
millième à 1 10 millièmes du coude
havas humain c'est de vous dire que
l'énergie ne vaut rien et sur les 40
dernières années
elle est passée de rien a encore moins
qu'est-ce qu'on utilise comme énergie en
france alors il ya une confusion qui est
souvent faite par les journalistes dans
ce pays qui est de confondre énergie
électricité au motif que les seuls
dispositifs de production que nous avons
dans notre pays c'est plus des puits de
pétrole et c'est plus des puits de gaz
est plus des mines de charbon mais c'est
des centrales électriques
une confusion est fait en permanence je
dis bien en permanence entre énergie
électricité
alors si je regarde l'énergie que
consomment les français qu'est ce que je
vais trouver je vais trouver pour
l'essentiel des combustibles fossiles
importées donc il a fallu un peu pompé
pour les extraire du sol et il faut les
faire venir chez nous c'est pour
l'essentiel
l'énergique nous utilisons l'essentiel
de l'énergie que nous utilisons en
france et fossiles la part du pétrole
dans la consommation des français est
exactement la même que la part du
pétrole dans la consommation des anglais
ou des allemands ou des italiens ou même
des américains il en consomme un peu
plus que nous mais pas beaucoup
donc contrairement à une idée couramment
des valeurs répandue le nucléaire ne
sert pas à éviter du pétrole il sert à
éviter du gaz et du charbon ce qui est
mon point de vue est une excellente idée
mais il ne sert pas à économiser du
pétrole voilà je vous ai mis là à ce que
représente le chauffage électrique
alors c'est important mais enfin c'est
loin d'être l'essentiel notez également
que dans les bâtiments c'est à dire ce
qu'on appelle résidentiel ici et
tertiaire là le chauffage électrique
c'est moins d'électricité que ce qui est
consommé pour le reste donc dit
autrement ce qui augmente le plus vite
aujourd'hui dans les bâtiments c'est pas
les dlc pas l'électricité qui sert à se
chauffer c'est l'électricité qui sert à
tout le reste les machines qui montent
et qui descendent qui cuisent qui
refroidissent qui tourne qui tripotent
qui fait pourquoi qui nous permettent de
nous amener des tas d'imagés
extraordinaires mais c'est pas le
chauffage qui est à l'origine de
l'essentiel de la consommation
électrique dans les bâtiments alors de
là il ya quelque chose qui n'est pas un
prix micro économiques mais qui est un
raisonnement macroéconomique très
important à garder en tête qu'ils aient
que les la notion de coûts et de prix
est quelque chose qui pour moi n'a pas
nécessairement beaucoup de sens et je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi
assez haut chaude sanitaire excusez moi
alors chauffage du gcs est à gauche
donc c'est des usages thermiques de
l'électricité et autres c'est tous les
usages spécifiques qui sont à droite
donc en gros c'est tous les moteurs
électriques comme je disais tout à
l'heure des frigos des pompes des
machines à laver enfin dans les machines
à laver sont dans le nord action entre
autres des appareils audiovisuels de
l'autre les ampoules électriques
voilà et le haut très supérieurs et il
croît plus vite je vous ai pas mis
l'évolution de la consommation
d'électricité en france mais de mémoire
elle est passée entre 1970 pour faire
honneur à nos amis belges est
aujourd'hui de 50 térawattheures a
quasiment
entre 250 et 300 d'accord donc c est là
qu a résidé l'essentiel de
l'augmentation et c'est pas pour
l'essentiel due aux chauffages
électriques alors ça n'empêche pas de
chauffage électrique des trains sujet
mais je ne faisais pas le principal
alors voilà une des conclusions que je
tire de ce que je viens de vous exposer
qui est que les outils de pilotage
macroéconomique que nous avons
aujourd'hui à notre disposition sont
totalement trompeur
donc ça c'est l'un des problèmes sur
lesquels on va souvent buté quand on
fait des comparaisons économique
l'économie que vous avez apprise à
l'école et moi aussi c'est celle là vous
avez deux facteurs de production le
capital et le travail
et donc quand le pib flag à douille ce
qui inquiète fortement tous les élus qui
se respecte alors on des taxes un peu le
travail on met un peu de crédit en
circulation pour augmenter le capital et
hop le pib reprend un coup de jeune
alors en fait ça marche pas puisque
depuis maintenant 40 ans nous avons trop
de travail puisqu'on a du chômage
structurel
on a trop de capital puisqu'on a des
bulles spéculatives dans tous les sens
et pourtant le pib flag à douille tout
autant donc ça veut dire que c'est pas
la bonne représentation du système la
bonne représentation du système pour moi
elle est là le la machine économique
mondiale n'est qu'une machine à
transformer des ressources gratuites
avec du travail humain ou venant des
machines je vais y venir et qui vous
transforme ça en autre chose
tout ce que vous avez dans cette salle
et qui est accessible à votre regard
tout ce qui sera accessible à votre
regard quand vous sortirez de cette
salle n'est rien d'autre que des
ressources naturelles transformé de la
main de l'homme
rien d'autre il n'y a rien d'autre dans
cette salle que ça les ressources
naturelles c'est le fruit de 15
milliards d'années d'évolution plus de
big bang
gratuit tous gratuits y compris le
pétrole le gaz le charbon l'uranium tout
gratuit les partisans des énergies
renouvelables dit souvent le vent et le
soleil sont gratuits mais le pétrole est
tout aussi gratuit ce qui coûte quelque
chose dans le pétrole c'est le coût
d'accès à la ressource qui a la mauvaise
idée d'être sous les pieds de monsieur
dupont et pas sous les pieds de monsieur
durand
mais la formation de la ressource
gratuit personne dans cette salle ni
ailleurs n'a payé le moindre centime
pour que se forment le pétrole donc des
ressources et du reste personne n'a payé
le moindre centime pour que se forment
les atomes de fer et les atomes de
cuivre et les atomes de manganèse
et le patrimoine de la de la
biodiversité actuelle ni rien tout ça
est gratuit donc on prend ces ressources
gratuites
on les transforme avec notre travail et
on en fait autre chose la formation de
capital n'est qu'une boucle internes au
système le capital c'est des ressources
et du travail passer l'immeuble dans
lequel nous sommes par exemple c'est du
travail et des ressources passé alors
dans cette affaire le travail qui permet
de transformer les ressources avec
l'ordre de grandeur que je vous ai
exposé est fourni par nos muscles pour 1
et par l'énergie des machines pour 200
alors maintenant vous avez une
représentation qui commencent à vous
expliquer ce qui se passe depuis 35 ans
si vous avez un problème en volume et
c'est pas une affaire de prix c'est une
affaire de volume
j'y viendrai après sur l'énergie vous
avez en problème en volume sur le pib
quel que soit le prix auquel les gens
ont accès à l'énergie
je vais vous prendre un exemple
caricatural si demain matin je rationne
le carburant et je divise les volumes
disponibles par dix le fait que les gens
puissent acheter leur litre de carburant
à 50 centimes à un euro ou un euro
cinquante n'est pas la question je
divise instantanément les flux de
transport par dix et en première
approximation je divise le pib français
par n'importe quoi entre 5 et 20 donc ce
n'est pas une affaire de prix de
l'énergie c'est une affaire de quantités
disponibles tant qu'on est dans un
marché parfait les deux sont corrélés
mais le marché n'est pas parfait et il
ya des tas de régulation qui se passe
hors marché il ya des tas de régulation
qui se passe en marché donc si un
rationnement est une régulation hors
marché un quota et une régulation hors
marché une norme est une régulation hors
marché l'interdiction est une régulation
hors marché donc donc l'histoire des du
prix et du volume qui sont parfaitement
a servi dans un monde à l'information
parfaite et c'est avec des phénomènes
parfaitement lisse c'est parce c'est pas
ça la vie et ce qui compte encore une
fois c'est les volumes et je vous
montrerai après deux courbes qui sont
très cohérente est ce que je suis en
train de vous raconter et c'est
exactement ce qui se passe en france
depuis le premier choc pétrolier nous
avons déjà une contrainte sur les
volumes
déjà alors cette contrainte elle est
dans une limitation de la hausse pas
encore dans une baisse mais elle a fait
passer je vous montrerai après une
petite règle de trois la croissance du
pib de 3% par an 1 % par an par personne
et depuis nous avons un déficit
structurel du chômage et des tas de
petits inconvénients qu'on n'est pas
prêt de réseaux de demain matin si vous
avez en plus une pression sur les
ressources vous
également avoir une pression sur la
production quelle que soit la quantité
d'énergie disponible
un exemple si vous n'avez plus de
poissons dans la mer sachant que le pib
de la pêche c'est la valeur des poissons
pêchés
vous pouvez avoir tous les chalutiers du
monde avec toute l'énergie disponible
pour les chalutiers du monde vous
passerez pas un poisson et votre pays
véhicules d'accord donc et or je le
répète
ni le stock de poissons ni le stock de
pétrole ne sont nulle part valorisé dans
les représentations économiques que nous
avons donc le prix de l'énergie c'est
une vision très partielle sur
l'importance du système énergétique dans
le fonctionnement des sociétés modernes
les déterminants du premier ordre c'est
combien y en a combien chemin en avoir
c'est ça les déterminants du premier
rang alors voilà un premier graphique
qui a créé disent que je vais vous dire
vous avez ici retracée depuis 1960
la variation en violet de la
consommation d'énergie de la planète et
en bleu du pib mondial
donc vous voyez que les deux sont
extrêmement bien corrélé en rapport avec
ce que je viens de vous deux vous de
vous raconter
donc en gros la première partie de cette
intervention la voici résumé mère nature
nous a donné gratuitement des
combustibles fossiles qui ont la bonne
idée de brûler et cette combustion nous
a donné les moteurs et la chimie et les
moteurs et la chimie nous en donner la
totalité des machines qui nous entoure
et par ricochet ça nous a donné une
productivité du travail en très forte
hausse qui a structuré la totalité de
nos acquis sociaux
même le divorce est un fruit de ça quand
vous divorcez vous doubler le nombre de
logements qu'il faut avoir
et vous le savez très bien la crise des
logements est notamment dû au divorce
vous augmenter d'un facteur 2 la
quantité d'énergie qu'il faut avoir pour
chauffer les logements d'un facteur de
la quantité d'énergie qu'il faut avoir
pour fabriquer tous les objets de la vie
courante les tables et chaises les lits
les télévisions et c'est que les gens
vont avoir un double plus le transport
des enfants quand il y en a un domicile
à l'autre plus la facture du psychiatre
parce que la garde alternée est très
mauvaise pour leur santé mentale dont
tous ceux que je viens d'évoquer si
c'est pas une blague
une étude épidémiologique qui vient de
le montrer ya pas longtemps voilà donc
l'énergie des serveurs de meetic enfin
tout y est donc ce que je sais pas une
blague
en fait le calcul montre que le divorce
augmente instantanément la consommation
d'énergie des ex conjoints de l'ordre de
60%
on ne divorce pas dans les pays qui
n'ont pas d'énergie on ne divorce pas
dans les pays qui n'ont pas d'énergie
ça nous a donné l' urbanisation
l'urbanisation croissante est une
fonction de l'énergie croissante
pourquoi parce que quand vous avez plein
d'énergie qui font fonctionner plaint de
machines
vous avez la possibilité d'enlever les
agriculteurs deschamps et d'enlever les
ouvriers des usines et à ce moment tout
le monde peut être assis dans un bureau
à échanger des informations
notre métier là tout de suite en ce
moment c'est d'échanger des informations
on ne produit rien de physique l'a tout
de suite peut-être une feuille de papier
dans un coin même s'il n'ya rien de
physique on est en train d'échanger des
informations mon métier ne sert qu'à ça
je fais des informations toute la
journée comme le comptable comme le
banquier comme l'employé qui traite vos
feuilles de sécu
tous ces gens la traitent des
informations et ils ont les moyens de le
faire parce que ailleurs les machines
s'occupe des flux physiques pour eux de
faire leurs vêtements de faire leur
nourriture de faire leur voiture de
faire leur logement et c'est donc une
société fortement urbanisée et fortement
tertiarisée n'est pas une société
fortement dématérialisé c'est au
contraire l'aboutissement ultime de
d'une société fortement consommatrices
d'énergie c'est au contraire cet
aboutissement ultime
je voulais pas mise mais si je vous
mettais la courbe des coûts de la
consommation d'énergie par personne en
fonction de la part du tertiaire dans
l'emploi vous verriez qui a une très
belle corrélation à la hausse et pas du
tout une corrélation à la baisse
très bonne corrélation à la housse en
plus dans tertiaire vous avez tous les
services de transports qui sont pas
spécialement dématérialisé donc ce que
je suis en train de vous dire c'est que
l'énergie a joué un rôle central là
dedans et c'est d'ailleurs qui vous
parle c'est pas la technique la
technique vous permet de faire un
ordinateur pour que chacun puisse avoir
son ordinateur pour 500 euros faut de
l'énergie à gogo pour les fabriquer
surtout pour les faire fonctionner un
peu alors deux questions se posent là
dedans évidemment et ça va avoir un
impact déterminant sur ce que je vais
vous raconter après sur l'électricité
1 est ce qu'il ya un goulet
d'étranglement en amont dans cette
affaire sur l'accès aux combustibles
fossiles et de est-ce qu'on a un goulet
d'étranglement en aval sur le changement
climatique induit par le fait de
rajouter du co2 dans l'atmosphère
alors je vais très rapidement traiter
les deux questions la première fait
appel un titre n 2 bat il se trouve que
les combustibles fossiles mettre des
centaines de millions d'années à se
former
donc aux échelles de temps qui nous
intéresse le charbon 300 millions
d'années le pétrole 50 pour faire les
choses ça sent plutôt aux échelles de
temps qui nous intéresse on peut donc
considérer que le stock extractible de
combustibles fossiles et donner une fois
pour toutes je sais pas exactement l
avance
qu'il est mais il est donnée une fois
pour toutes alors les maths vous
permettre de dire que quand vous tapez
dans un stock de départ qui est donnée
une fois pour toutes
vous ne pouvez pas avoir une extraction
indéfiniment croissante en provenance de
ce stock je crois qu'on sera d'accord
stock est infinie vous ne pouvez même
pas avoir une extraction indéfiniment
constante en provenance de ce stock même
ça c'est pas possible
la seule chose que les mac vous autorise
et ça se démontre c'est que à ce moment
l'extraction de votre stock par 2 0
termine à 0 et passe par un maximum
entre les deux c'est vrai pour le
pétrole
c'est vrai pour le gaz c'est vrai pour
le charbon et ça sera vrai pour tous les
minerais métalliques que nous avons sur
cette bonne vieille terre tous pour tous
vous aurez donc une entité mathématiques
qui s'appelle le pic alors ça peut être
maintenant où ça peut être en l'an 3000
253 ou en lan 10 1758 ça peut être au
niveau actuel de production ou à 45 fois
le niveau actuel de production sas et
des débats sérieux
par contre cette entité existe sept
objets existent c'est pas un truc qui
n'arrivera pas cet objectif est encore
une fois ça se démontre
alors on va parler du pétrole il ya un
premier pic qui est très facile à
prédire c'est celui qui est déjà passé
et c'est le pic des découvertes
vous avez ici une courbe qui vous donne
les découvertes de pétrole extractible
sur terre vous voyez que c'est passer
par un maximum pas très loin de l'année
de ma naissance j'ai pas si un rapport
entre les deux paco rabanne dirais pour
les banques oui et au moment où je vous
parle on a découvert un peu plus de 2000
milliards en chai désole le monde de
l'énergie est bourré d'unités anglo
saxon ça les anglo saxons font rien
comme tout le monde
donc ils ont des barils des pieds cubes
des onze des pousses favon le système
batterie qui n'aime pas ça et alors
l'unité de base dans le monde pétrolier
c'est le baril qui fait 159 litres ou là
je suis vraiment désolé et les
pétroliers alors comptés en millions de
barils par jour et en milliards de
barils extractible voilà c'est leur dada
alors le pétrole extractible connu au
moment où je vous parle il faut
prolonger un peu la cour parce que ce
truc là d'il ya quelques années est un
peu supérieure à 2000 milliards de
barils et de ses 2000 milliards de
barils nous avons fait sortir en
quantité croissante jusqu'en 2005 est
stable depuis 2005 la production
mondiale de pétrole n'augmente plus
depuis 2005 à peu près 1200 milliards de
barils donc à peu près la moitié
et compte tenu du délai moyen qui sépare
le pic des découvertes du pic de
production et qui se vérifie dans toutes
les grandes zones pétrolières et bien le
maximum de la production mondiale de
pétrole on y est l' agence
internationale de l'énergie a même fini
par avouer que ça c'était probablement
passé en 2006 alors comment fait on va
être sur un plateau ondulant le fait de
savoir exactement où se trouve le
maximum a pas beaucoup d'intérêt en
première approximation on peut retenir
que maintenant la production annuelle de
pétrole est devenu stable au niveau
actuel alors ça va cette stabilité va
être plus ou moins longue
en fonction de la récupération plus ou
moins forte qui va y avoir dans ce qui a
déjà été découverts et du supplément de
découverte qui va y avoir à partir de
maintenant
retenez que sur ce graphique les
découvertes qui ont été faites au large
du brésil
le soap salt la dent vous avez peut-être
entendu parler ça représente quelque
chose qui est à peu près à ce niveau là
donc on est très très loin des 50
milliards de barils qu'on découvrait
tous les ans à l'époque de l'âge d'or
des découvertes où on farfouille est où
les ingénieurs de schlumbergera fouiller
dans le dans les pays qui bordent le
golfe persique
maintenant quand on découvre un gisement
absolument astronomique on parle de
quelques milliards de barils ces salles
ordre de grandeur
donc on va avoir un plateau qui va durer
selon le consensus aux alentours
jusqu'aux alentours de 2020 avant un
déclin absolument inexorable que
l'automobiliste français trouve ça
rigolo ou pas et que le gestionnaire des
turbines à fuel trouve ça rigolo ou pas
et que l'utilisateur de sur le lourd
trop ça rigolo ou pas il va y avoir un
déclin alors évidemment la question
c'est que va être le prix à ce moment là
est d'abord je pense que c'est pas le
sujet parce que j'ai dit le sujet c'est
pour moi c'est des volumes
et ensuite quand on voit les gens qui
sont essayés à faire des pronostics sur
le prix dans le passé je pense qu'il
faut rester extrêmement modeste
vis-à-vis de ce genre d'exercice et pour
être un peu plus provocant des goûts et
quelqu'un vous faire une prévision de
prix à 20 ans sur le pétrole ne
l'écoutait pas vous gagnerez du temps
ici vous avez la seule certitude qu'on a
c'est que ça va devenir volatile pour le
reste ici vous avez le prix du pétrole
tels qu'il a vraiment été jusqu'en 2010
et là vous avez les projections de tri
qui ont été faites à des après année par
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
voilà bon et j'en vois au moins que ça
fait rire moi aussi ça va beaucoup fait
rigoler quand j'ai vu ça
donc dit autrement savoir ce que va
devenir le prix du pétrole pour une
denrée aussi essentiel avec un marché
dans lequel il ya des billets dans tous
les sens et une incertitude sur l'avenir
qui va croissant ça n'a aucun sens aucun
sens je ne sais pas ce que sera le prix
du pétrole
mais encore une fois c'est pas ça la
question parce que la question c'est les
volumes alors je vais revenir à mon pib
et je vais vous refaire une petite règle
de trois
partagez vous faire une petite règle de
trois qui va qui va vous expliquer
pourquoi je vois l'énergie ale pib si
fortement lié alors je commence ma règle
de trois en disant que le pib est égal à
lui même j'ai pris l'acronyme anglais
pardon parce que je me sers de temps en
temps de ce genre de truc devant des
publics anglophones
j'espère qu'on sera d'accord là dessus
je dis lisais je multiplie par l'énergie
consommée par les gens oui gross
domestic product c'est l'acronyme
anglais pour pib domestic product jeudi
viser je multiplie par l'énergie et puis
comme j'aime bien raisonné par individu
ge divise de chaque côté par la
population donc ce que je viens d'écrire
c'est que le pouvoir d'achat par
personne le pib par personne est égale à
la multiplication de l'énergie par
personne fois la quantité d'énergie dont
j'ai besoin pour faire 1 dollars de pib
c'est à dire l'efficacité énergétique de
l'économie et maintenant je vais
m'intéresser aux variations
alors vous savez que la variation d'une
somme due et l'avarice et un produit par
don c'est la somme des variations ainsi
à gauche ça augmente de 2% par an est à
droite ça augmente de 4% par an
l'ensemble augmente de 6 donc la
croissance du pib par personne
c'est la somme de la croissance de
l'énergie par personne dont vous voyez
pourquoi c'est si structurants et la
variation de l'efficacité énergétique de
l'économie
le terme de droite en moyenne mondiale a
crû de 2% par an entre le début de la
révolution industrielle et 1981 et
depuis c'est devenu nul en moyenne
mondiale face à 0 2% par an allez 0 ce
terme là augmente péniblement d'un petit
% par an depuis 1970 ce qui veut dire
que le terme de gauche qui concerne
essentiellement les économies dites
développées jusqu'en 1990 95 est passé
brutalement en 1981 pour des raisons
physiques pour des raisons physiques de
3% par an à 1 % par an
entraînant dans son sillage le début de
l'augmentation dès l'apparition puis
l'augmentation de la dette des états
souverains
l'endettement des ménages et des
entreprises la variole la volatilité sur
le prix de l'énergie
l'apparition du chômage structurel qui
sauf l'épisode de 29 n'existait pas
avant
bref tous les petits désagréments qu
aujourd'hui on vous promet qu'on va
résoudre la prochaine élection et qui
bien évidemment hors plan marshall ne
sont pas résolus
donc le c'est juste pour dire que toute
réflexion prospective sur le prix de
l'énergie et c'est là dessus que je
voulais en venir doit s'inscrire dans un
contexte dans lequel il n'y aura pas le
retour à la croissance
j'y crois pas à cause de ça parce que je
suis en france
alors vous pouvez prendre sur sa sur
n'importe quelle frontière géographique
là en l'occurrence je viens de vous
donner quelque chose qui vaut pour le
monde dans son ensemble monde mais si
j'avais fait la même chose pour la
france j'aurais le pour les etats unis
c'est à peu près comme ça et ça descend
légèrement ici et pour la france c'est à
peu près comme ça et ça descend
légèrement ici aussi d'accord là c'est
donc pour le monde entier et énergie oui
le volume c'est pas le prix c'est la
quantité d'énergie par personne donc
c'est des kilowatts heure par personne
et par an d'accord comme on vous le
calculer l'énergie la personne ah bah ça
c'est très simple il suffit de regarder
la la production mondiale d'énergie et
vous diviser sa part la consommation
mondiale d'énergie d'eau par la
population mondiale donc vous prenez la
quantité totale de pétrole qui sort du
sol de gaz qui sort du sol de charbon
qui sort du sol d'électricité qui sort
des centrales nucléaires d'électricité
qui sort des barrages des lecteurs de
kilowattheures qui sortent du bois dans
la biomasse le reste est négligeable et
vous diviser sa part la population
mondiale et ça vous donne la quantité
d'énergie consommée par personne et par
an toutes les énergies pas s'exprimant
kilowattheure est une unité que vous
pouvez utiliser pour toutes les énergies
donc ce que dit ce petit calcul c'est
que encore une fois toute prospective
sur les infos les investissements dans
les infrastructures énergétiques doit à
mon sens je ne fais que vous livrer une
opinion s'envisager dans un contexte
dans lequel nous ne retrouverons pas une
croissance économique forte
c'est fini
alors pensez que c'est un bien ou un mal
là n'est pas la question la question
c'est si gérer c'est prévoir
je pense que c'est ça qu'il faut prévoir
alors voilà une illustration de cette
corrélation dans le passé ici vous avez
en violet la variation de la production
mondiale de pétrole
on sait une production de pétrole c'est
pas le prix du pétrole c'est la quantité
de pétrole qui à notre disposition et en
bleu vous avez la variation du pib par
personne et tout ça démarre en 1968 et
vous voyez que contrairement à une idée
couramment répandue lacovar iations d2
ici elle est plus elle est meilleure que
ici où le pétrole pouvait varier plus
fortement s'en trouve affecté le pays
des dons contrairement à une idée
couramment répandue
l'économie n'est pas moins sensible
aujourd'hui à la quantité de pétrole
accessible elle l'est plus les plus les
transports sont devenus plus importants
dans une économie mondialisée et vous
voyez aussi que sur les deux derniers
épisodes de crise qu'on a connu c'est
pas la chute du pib qui entraîne la
chute du pétrole celle inverse
c'est la chute du pétrole qui entraîne
la chute du pib ce qui est le reflet
pour moi de l'effet volume donc en gros
quand vous avez un problème sur le
pétrole comme le pétrole se vend sur des
marchés vous avez un choc pétrolier mais
comme par ailleurs le volume de pétrole
pilote pib vous avez aussi une baisse du
pib et la baisse du pib n'est pas juste
un effet inflationniste de la hausse du
pétrole
c'est pas juste ça donc c'est pour vous
dire que à mon avis le et qu'est ce qui
va se passer sur le volume de pétrole à
l'avenir voilà la réponse pour l'europe
ici vous avez la quantité totale de
pétrole à disposition de l'europe depuis
1965 en rose vous avez la production
domestique
donc vous avez ici un petit talon de
production qui vient historiquement des
pays de l'est qui sont pas très loin de
la caspienne et ici vous avez la mer du
nord qui monte en production qui passe
par son pic en 2000 et qui depuis
décline à raison de 5 à 8% par an et là
vous avez les importations en provenance
du reste du monde qui font la différence
et vous voyez que 1 les importations
représentent l'essentiel du pétrole
consommé par les européens et la danse
je vous ai même pas me l'union je vous
ai mis l'union plus la norvège
si je vous enlève la norvège je vous
enlève un bon morceau de ce truc rose 1
et le début du déclin à mon avis
terminal entre guillemets de l'axé
européen au pétrole date de 2005 donc
avant le grenelle est depuis 2005
l'europe a perdu 8% de son pétrole
parce que ici ça décline
là ça va décliner parce que la
production mondiale étant désormais
stable à cause de l'effet d'éviction du
aux émergents et aux pays consomme et
aux pays producteurs eux mêmes la
fraction résiduelle qui peut être mise
sur le marché mondial baisse donc ça ça
va baisser et donc le le vert là va
baisser
le rose va baisser et donc la totalité
du pétrole disponible a baissé il ya que
deux manières de faire baisser la
consommation de pétrole
le la hausse des prix forte et
absolument pas régulé où la récession
donc mon sentiment c'est qu'à partir de
maintenant nous entrons dans une ère
nouvelle de l'économie européenne dans
laquelle on va aussi y est en ski en ce
qui concerne le pétrole entre de fortes
hausses de prix et la récession et c'est
dans ce contexte là qu'il faudra piloter
nos investissements électrique alors
soit dit en passant parce que je sais
que ça a été un sujet ya pas longtemps
voilà comment se décompose le prix du
litre de super actuellement payés par
l'automobiliste l'essentiel c'est des
taxes mais pas que chez nous vous voyez
un car c'est des taxes dans les scellés
rendent de l'état producteurs
ici vous avez la tête était là vous avez
la tva et là vous avez le bénéfice de
l'affreux total alors on peut supprimer
le bénéfice de l'afro total c'est une
option si on en a envie
ça ne change que très marginalement le
prix payé à la pompe donc dit autrement
si je prends les 10 milliards d'euros de
bénéfices de total pour alléger le prix
à la pompe payés par les français
c'est sympathique ça m'enlève 2 ou 3
centimes enfin dans 5 centimes plus
exactement mais bon ça change pas
tellement les ordres de grandeur et en
particulier ça ne change pas ça qui
dépend de la rareté du produit à
l'évidence et ça ne change pas ça dont
les coûts marginaux augmente très
fortement très fortement sur les
nouveaux gisements mis en exploitation
donc voilà tout ça pour vous dire le
plus grand mal que je pense de la
proposition je ne sais pas quels sont
les appartenances ici que je pense de la
proposition de d'instaurer la tlpe est
flottante qui à mon avis est une
subvention directe aux recettes à
l'exportation des qatari des russes et
des libyens je sais qu'ils nous aiment
beaucoup et qu'il faut beaucoup les
payer mais enfin bon peut-être qu'on a
des choses plus intelligentes à faire
avec notre argent
pour respecter les deux vis des
entrepreneurs c'était ça s'est basé sur
l'idée que le prix du pétrole finira par
se calmer et moi je vous dis une chose
ça n'arrivera que dans un contexte de
récession
donc ça veut dire que tant qu'ils aient
un peu de pétrole qui se vend on
appauvrit l'état pour qu'ensuite on
l'appauvrissent encore plus quand on
arrive dans la récession
je ne suis pas sûr encore une fois que
ce soit le truc le plus utile à faire
avec notre pognon pardon avec 900 en ce
qui concerne le gaz le gaz se formant
géologiquement au même endroit que le
pétrole
il est découvert à peu près en même
temps que le pétrole dans une première
époque il n'intéressait pas du tout les
pétroliers quand ils trouvaient du gars
c'était une vraie calamité
maintenant ils les intéressent mais il
ya une raison au fait qu'ils les
intéressait pas du tout il ya une époque
c'est que contrairement aux prix du
pétrole ou le pétrole s'est très c'est
un peu cher à extraire et quasi gratuit
à transporter le coût du gaz livré dans
le pays importateur et compte plus de
transport que l'extraction le gaz et
gazeux et à cause de cette
caractéristique tout bête
les capitaux nécessaires pour le
transporter sont beaucoup plus
importants que pour le pétrole qui est
liquide à température ordinaire et donc
ils se transportent avec une densité
d'énergie par unité de volume qui est
beaucoup plus importante donc le gaz
obéit à la loi de marriott que pauvre et
donc il faut mettre beaucoup plus
d'argent sur la table pour transporter
du gaz que pour transporter du pétrole
ceci explique cela les deux tiers du
pétrole extrait sur terre passe une
frontière avant d'être consommée ça
n'est vrai que pour 25% du gaz mondiales
et au sein de ses 25% ça n'est vrai que
pour lui pour cent du gaz qui transporte
qui transitent sur la planète sous forme
de gnl de gaz liquéfiés donc le marché
mondial du gaz liquéfié ses 8 % de la
consommation mondiale de gaz alors que
le marché mondial du gaz qui se baladent
dans des pétroliers c'est plus près de
la moitié donc la seule vraie énergie
internationale qu on s et le pétrole
les autres sont des énergies régionales
comme le gaz ou domestiques comme le
charbon donc le pic de produits le pic
des découvertes de gaz a déjà été passé
depuis longtemps alors l'appareil même
histoire la production va monter puis
elle va descendre alors il va y avoir un
peu on va racler un peu mieux les
réservoirs c'est plus dur que pour le
pétrole parce qu on dégonfle un truc
essentiellement on va redécouvrir trois
trucs et tout ça va nous mettre dans un
pic qui arrive
selon les régions entre maintenant et
2050 voilà l'approvisionnement gazier de
l'europe
vous voyez que ça s'inverse par rapport
au pétrole les importations ne font que
40% par contre la mer du nord qui fait
des 60%
restant à passer son pic dans les années
2000 elle est en léger déclin pour le
moment et quand la norvège passera son
pic d'ici à 2020 le déclin va fortement
s'accélérer alors là j'en tire une
conclusion que je vais vous livrer plus
tard l'idée sympathique qu'on puisse
même en période de transition
remplacer la moindre centrales
nucléaires par du gaz en europe se fera
nécessairement au détriment d'une
consommation de gaz existantes ailleurs
nécessairement on ne peut pas rajouter
du gaz à la consommation actuelle de
l'europe qui est déjà parti à la baisse
ce que vient de faire madame merkel en
décidant de relancer le planchot d'heure
en disant qu'elle va remplacer son
nucléaire par du gaz venu de russie en
ayant eu la bonne idée de se mettre
juste au bout du tuyau aura un effet
d'éviction direct sur le consommateur
français direct alors c'est son droit de
le faire
les textes européens de l'ue interdisent
pas il faut juste qu'on comprenne bien
en france ce que ça signifie ça va avoir
un effet d'éviction direct sur le
consommateur français
on vous a probablement parlé des gaz de
schiste alors là encore la presse a eu
la langue qui a fourché c'est pas des
gaz de schiste pour l'essentiel c'est
des gaz d'autres choses
les gaz non conventionnel ou si vous
avez la production de gaz non
conventionnel aux états unis fait appel
à trois familles de gaz
une petite partie c'est du gaz de
schiste qu'en fait il convient d'appeler
du gaz de roche mère c'est du gaz qui
s'est formée dans la roche dans laquelle
il y avait les sédiments organique qui
permettent la formation du pétrole et du
gaz et qui n'a pas quitté cette roche
mais l'essentiel des gaz non
conventionnel aux états unis aujourd'hui
viennent de deux autres catégories le
gaz de charbon c'est tout simplement du
grisou donc en gros vous fracturé la
veine de charbon et vous récupérez
grisou qui contient essentiellement du
méthane et du gaz de réservoir compact
le réservoir compact c'est un réservoir
de gaz conventionnel c'est du gaz qui a
migré depuis la roche-mère vers une
roche réservoir et simplement la roche
réservoir c'est un peureux sédimenter
après et donc la perméabilité des plus
assuré et il faut recréer de la
perméabilité en fracturant la roche
c'est aussi des techniques de
fracturation
géologiquement ça n'a rien à voir
retrouvez du gaz de réservoir compact là
où vous trouver du gaz tout court vous
trouver du gaz de roche mère là où il ya
des roches mères peut-être en france il
n'est pas du tout du conte et du gaz de
roche mère dans les roches mères on sait
qu'on a des roches mères parce que ça
c'est le seul truc qu'on puisse savoir
depuis la surface pour savoir s'il ya du
gaz dedans pour faire un trou alors je
suis pas en train de vous dire qu'il
faut faire le trou jeu juste en train de
vous dire
techniquement vous ne pouvez pas savoir
s'il ya du gaz ou pas dans la roche mère
quand vous avez pas fait le trou je vous
rappelle qu'en ce qui concerne le
pétrole quand vous trouvez une formation
géologique que vous soupçonnez de
contenir du pétrole cinq puits
d'exploration sur 600 sec 5 sur 6 dont
vous trouvez depuis la surface
une formation géologique dont vous vous
dites tiens ça par échographie passée de
la sismique 1 donc vous dites qu'un là
dedans il ya peut-être du pétrole et
vous allez faire le trou 5 fois sur 6
syrien donc qu on est en europe en
france en particulier des gaz de schiste
% rien peut-être que oui peut-être que
non faut les voir si on veut vraiment
savoir
peut-être qu'on veut pas savoir puisque
est un débat en soi mais si on veut
savoir faut aller voir y'a pas d'autres
moyens
est ce que en europe on a des gaz de
réservoir compact la réponse est non et
est-ce qu'on a du gaz de charbon chez
les gens qui ont du charbon la réponse
est oui et en france comme il ya plus de
charbon ou très peu la réponse est non
donc confondre gaz de schiste avec gaz
non conventionnel schiste avec gaz de
schiste et tout extrapoler à la france
est quelque chose qui est
malheureusement de mauvais raccourcis
médiatiques
la réalité c'est qu'on ne sait pas s'il
ya un approvisionnement en gaz de
schiste en provenance de la france
et quand bien même il y en aurait un
c'est considérablement plus
capitalistiques que le gaz conventionnel
tout le gaz du gisement de lacq est
sorti par un seul troupes un seul est un
seul forage d'exploration et
d'exploitation dans le gisement gazier
de lacq là avec les gaz non
conventionnel voudrez d une surface qui
est de l'or du kilomètre carré quand
vous quelques kilomètres carrés quand
vous faites un puits donc faut faire un
puits tous les kilomètres en gros donc
je vous laisse imaginer un puits tous
les kilomètres dans les cévennes
encore une fois on peut le souhaiter
mais c'est ce genre de truc qu'il faut
avoir en tête faut pouvoir forer de plus
facilement il faut avoir l'argent pour
forer les pieds en permanence un très
capitalistique voilà alors maintenant
revenons-en à l'électricité avec quoi
fait-on l'électricité en europe
ça peut-être que vous l'avez déjà vu au
stade où vous en êtes c'est une carte
dans laquelle vous avez les sources
d'énergie utilisées pour faire de
l'électricité un peu partout en europe
comme vous le savez l'énergie ne sort
pas du mur contrairement au saut la
réponse à un sondage classique qui a été
fait aux états unis faut la faire à
partir d'autres choses alors cet autre
chose
il est en europe pour beaucoup du
charbon nos amis allemands font la
moitié de leur électricité du charbon et
du reste l'énergie quand cet allemand
s'est pas du tout de faire des éoliennes
c'est de faire du charbon et du gaz pour
l'essentiel donc ils vont
ils vont ils ont 20 gigawatts de
capacités fossiles en construction pour
des commissionné les 23 gigawatts de
nucléaire qu'ils ont actuellement en
service et ils vont faire
essentiellement du gaz et du charbon
alors avec un peu de chance la
population diminuera suffisamment vite
pour que leurs émissions de co2
n'augmente pas mais c'est l'effet
combiné du vieillissement de la
population et du gaz et du charbon qui
va être le plan allemand de transition
énergétique
alors moi je veux bien que la presse
française apollo listé quatre mains
enfin j'ai quelques doutes sur le côté
écologique du machin donc le charbon 30
un tiers de l'électricité européenne
après vous avez du gaz qui fait de
l'ordre de 15 à 20 %
et comme je voulais montrer tout à
l'heure ce gaz on est déjà dans la
seringue
c'est à dire que la quantité de gaz qui
est disponible est quelque chose qui est
déjà parti à la baisse
on a également de l'hydroélectricité que
je vais évoquer juste après et enfin on
a du vent alors le vent c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas significatif
aujourd'hui à l'échelle européenne et la
question de savoir si ça peut devenir
significatif devrait faire l'objet de
beaucoup plus de temps que je n'en ai
aujourd'hui
retenez juste quelques conclusions
simple il n'existe pas aujourd'hui de
foisonnement éolien en europe c'est pas
vrai quand vous faites la somme des
puissances injectée sur le réseau de
l'espagne de la grande-bretagne de
l'allemagne de la france
vous vous rendez compte que ou bien il
ya une dépression sur la façade
atlantique et ça produit ou n'y a pas de
dépression et ça produit pas c'est en
première approximation à peu près ce qui
se passe vous n'avez pas d'effet de
compensation entre le nord et le sud
la deuxième chose qu'il faut savoir et
ça c'est un sujet de réflexion pour vous
je suis dans les tarifs de rachat
favorable à ce qu'on limite les tarifs
de rachat à l'électricité garantie sinon
ça veut dire que l'on m'ait
l'intermittence induites à la charge de
quelqu'un d'autre ailleurs dans le
réseau et je vois pas pourquoi on
subventionnerait monsieur à
pour m une charge chez monsieur b sans
prévenir monsieur b et sans dire qui est
monsieur b les moyens l'intermittence
induites oblige d'autres personnes à
avoir des moyens de backup ou des moyens
de stockage ou de l'effacement de
consommation donc dit autrement
monsieur à je le paye pour me coller
l'intermittence dans un réseau
électrique qui aime pas ça et c'est
ailleurs que je vais gérer les surcoûts
qui en découlent donc je pense que ça
vaudrait le coup de distinguer les
tarifs de rachat en deux sous catégories
une sous-catégorie acquis et le
kilowattheure garantie c'est celui que
j'ai
j'en ai besoin de manière certaine le
barrage rentre dans cette catégorie et
le kilowattheure baisser le
kilowattheure qui arrive quand il en a
envie et celui là vont nécessairement
moins cher mais j'y reviendrai quand on
répondra aux questions
donc le ce qui veut dire qu'à
renouvelables et renouvelables elles
sont pas toutes
elles sont pas toutes si vous avez un
stock de bois et vous faites de
l'électricité à la demande c'est plus
garanti que si vous avez des sociétés
qui arrive quand le vent souffle donc
pour moi c'est 2 électricité là puisque
l'électricité ne se stocke pas en tant
que tel 1 vous stockez pas des électrons
en mouvement où stocker de l'eau remonté
en altitude une séparation chimique dans
une batterie mais vous stockez pas
l'électricité en tant que tel sauf dans
un supraconducteur enfin c'est un peu
cher donc vous devez si vous avez
quelque chose qui est intermittent et
fatale ça vaut nécessairement moins cher
dans un réseau électrique que quelque
chose qui est garanti et pilotable
nécessairement moins cher donc voilà
comment on fait l'électricité
aujourd'hui en europe alors avec tout ce
que je vous ai raconté comment vont
évoluer les prix exogènes
j'allais dire ce qui ne dépend pas des
décisions des français on va commencer
par s'intéresser aux prix du charbon que
vous avez à gauche qui pilote une partie
du coût de production de l'électricité
puisque dans une centrale à charbon le
coût du charbon c'est en gros 50 % du
coût de production du kilowattheure eh
bien vous voyez que le prix du charbon
c'est le graphique de gauche et très
bien corrélé au prix du pétrole et donc
comme le prix du pétrole je vous ai dit
qu'il allait monter sauf récession est
bien donc anti canton sera pas en
récession il va monter ça veut dire que
le prix du charbon va aussi faire le
yoyo indépendamment de toute
considération sur le co2 vous allez
avoir un prix de la production
électrique au charbon qui va monter en
ce qui concerne le gaz ces graphiques de
droite
alors ici vous l'avez mondialement
jusqu'au moment où les américains se
sont fortement décorrélée pour des
raisons de production domestique ça ne
change rien au destin des européens
comme vous l'avez probablement constaté
récemment donc pour les européens cela
va continuer à être asservis au prix du
pétrole donc l'électricité produite au
gaz
et là c'est 70% du coût du kilowattheure
va également voir son prix évoluer comme
le prix du gaz venant à
l'hydroélectricité
ici vous avez une simulation issus du
dernier rapport du giec enfin plus
exactement une synthèse des simulations
issus du dernier rapport du giec qui
vous donne l'évolution des
précipitations sur la planète
dans un scénario qui est qualifié de
charbon et c'est à dire qu'en gros on va
au maximum du charbon qu'on peut
consommer sur terre
avec un pic charbon aux alentours de
2050 et vous voyez ici la manière dont
évoluent les précipitations sur terre en
hiver dans l'hémisphère nord en été dans
l'hémisphère nord
et vous voyez que le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen s'assèchent en toute
saison et pour tous les modèles donc
l'hydraulicité que nous allons avoir en
europe va probablement baisser et
l'hydraulicité comme vous le voyez ici
pilote quand même une partie de
l'électricité que nous produisons et
surtout c'est la plus précieuse de
toutes les formes de production
électrique parce que c'est celle qui est
la plus modulable et la plus pilotable
le truc qui vous réagi qui vous délivre
deux gigawatts en trois minutes
c'est un barrage aucune autre forme de
production électrique ne sait faire ça
aucune donc le l'hydroélectricité est un
truc extrêmement précieux dans le
pilotage d'un réseau électrique et sur
cette hydroélectricité on va avoir une
contrainte à cause de la contrainte
climatique
ça va évoluer
c'est alors pardon ce qui est en rouge
ça c'est chez ce qui est en bleu vous
avez des précipitations qui augmente
d'accord et ça c'est la situation
actuelle non ça c'est l'évolution d'ici
à la fin du siècle donc en gros l'europe
devrait perdre 20 à 30% de ces
précipitations d'ici à la fin du siècle
d'accord lassé actuelle et c'est vers le
fennec absolument ce qui veut dire que
mais c'est pas con tinue cette affaire
c'est pas un pour cent par an à l'aîné
tu avais pas du tout l'idée r il va y
avoir des à-coups 2003 était un à-coup
2010 a été un à coup un essai à coups
vont se répéter
donc il va y avoir des situations de
tension mise sous tension du système qui
vont aller en a qu'en s'accroissant
quand vous avez des épisodes
caniculaires importants ou des grandes
sécheresses significative
vous avez deux inconvénients d'une part
vous avez d'hydraulicité qui baissent
donc les barrages se remplissent moins
bien et d'autre part vous avez des
problèmes sur le refroidissement des
centrales thermiques et il se trouve que
les centrales thermiques fond si vous
mettez boutabout nucléaire gaz et
charbon parce que tout ça c'était remis
qu'in vous représente en gros 75 %
d'électricité européennes
tous ces dispositifs là ont des
problèmes de refroidissement en période
de canicule
pas juste les centrales
r tous en 2013
en 2003 pardon dans l'es13 dérogation
que edf avait demandé sur ses centrales
thermiques
il y en a sept qui concernaient des
centrales nucléaires et si ce qui
concernait des centrales à charbon et au
pétrole
alors comme nous avons sortir du
nucléaire la presse a largement parlé
des centrales nucléaires et comme nous
n'avons pas sortir du charbon et du gaz
la presse n'a pas parlé des centrales à
charbon et à gaz et en pétrole
mais si ces fouilles exactement les
mêmes problèmes
si vous aussi à certains d'entre vous
prennent le tgv pour aller à marseille
de temps en temps quand vous passez à
côté de la centrale de gardanne
savez vous voyez des très beaux
aéroréfrigérants par la fenêtre c'est
une centrale à charbon moi je fais
souvent le test quand je suis avec des
gens dans le wagon je leur dis c'est
quoi ce truc à lui une centrale
nucléaire bas donc quand vous montrez
des aéroréfrigérants un américain il
pense enfin l'achat qu'on pense pas du
tout centrales nucléaires donc vous en
avez sur toutes les centrales thermiques
et je finis ce petit exposé avec les
énergies renouvelables aujourd'hui avant
de répondre à vos questions
alors les énergies renouvelables
aujourd'hui voici ce qu'elle représente
dans le monde
l'unité qui est utilisé sur ce graphique
c'est le million de tonnes équivalent
pétrole
je suis désolé pour cette unité barbare
et la consommation mondiale avec 7
unités vos 14000 donc la consommation
mondiale ces quatorze mille millions de
tonnes équivalent pétrole d'énergie là
dedans vous voyez que la première
énergie renouvelable et de très loin
c'est le bois qui fait à peu près 10% de
la consommation mondiale d'énergie
ensuite vous avez l'hydroélectricité qui
en équivalent primaire fait à peu près
5% de la consommation mondiale d'énergie
et ensuite vous tombez sous le % et pour
les énergies clairement électrique
j'évite les équivalents primaire et vous
vous rendez compte que les
agrocarburants s'est fait manger des
pizzas gris carburant sont pas du tout
bio c'est 0 5% de l'énergie mondiale
c'est 1,5 pour cent du pétrole mondial
ridicule et pour ça on est déjà en train
d'affamer une partie des gens les
américains ont totalement ah si si si ça
fait quinze ou vingt ans que les
américains ont affecté la totalité de la
hausse de leur production de maïs et de
l'éthanol le mexique pour le moment on
peut encore se payer des importations
max et de maïs parce qu'ils allaient il
a des excédents pétroliers ses excédents
pétroliers vont s'arrêter dans quatre
cinq ans parce que la production du
golfe du mexique dans la partie
mexicaine est en train de décliner à ce
moment là je ne sais pas ce qui se
passera au mexique mais il va se passer
des choses intéressantes donc le
le aujourd'hui il ya une pression sur
les cultures vivrières évidente du aux
agrocarburants absolument évidente c'est
pas la seule il y en a eu d'autres dû au
climat
évidemment là j'ai une partie de la
réponse à une autre question vous m'avez
posée est ce que ça vaut le coup de
maître des tarifs de rachat exorbitants
là dessus et là dessus quand on a un
problème sur quelque chose qui vaut 50
ou 100 fois ça ma réponse est non
c'est du gaspillage d'argent non ça ne
sert strictement à rien si je sers à se
faire plaisir
dit autrement tant qu'à de la croissance
parce qu'on a plein de gaz de charbon et
de pétrole
ça sert à se donner bonne conscience en
recyclant tran surplus le jour où
l'économie sera atteinte dans le dur
parce que pétrole gaz et charbon
commenceront à décliner pour de bon dans
l'approvisionnement français on arrêtera
de se livrer à ce genre de plaisanterie
je l'avais j'avais la première fois je
les écris c'était en 2004
donc la première fois que j'ai écrit
c'était en 2004 que les subventions au
photovoltaïque et à l'éolien
s'arrêterait au moment des récessions
qui serait justement due aux problèmes
que ça prétend éviter les jeux contes
nous y sommes voilà donc voila un petit
panorama sur quelques éléments de
réflexion qui à mon avis doivent
encadrer toute forme de réflexion sur
les tarifs de l'électricité en
particulier et de l'énergie en général
alors maintenant je peux répondre
rapidement aux questions ou moins
rapidement du reste aux questions qui
m'ont été posées avant peut-être son
faste et des questions sur ce que je
viens de présenter nous renouvelables
c'est le pétrole
oui je vous ai pas mis ça alors dans le
mix mondiale le pétrole représente un
tiers de l'énergie primaire et dans ce
qu'on appelle l'énergie finale c'est à
dire celle qui sort du système
énergétique etc est mise à la
disposition des consommateurs c'est au
dessus de 40 % donc le pétrole domine le
mix énergétique mondial de la tête et
des épaules et dans le système de
transport qui aujourd'hui est le sens du
système économique mondial
c'est 98 % la part du pétrole donc le
pétrole pilote c'est la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui le pétrole pilote
le pib en volume c'est vraiment ça si
demain matin je prie que la france de
transport paris meurent de faim vous
avez des émeutes partout enfin il
s'effondre donc le pétrole ensuite le
gaz et de pétrole ensuite au charbon
chabot alors pétrole c'est un tiers de
l'énergie mondiale charbon 25 gaz 20
biomasse 10 nucléaire hydroélectricité à
parité à 5 et le reste faire 2-1 et demi
autre précision le charbon sert
essentiellement à faire de l'électricité
à peu près les deux tiers du charbon
extrait sur la planète servent à faire
de l'électricité est symétriquement la
première source de production électrique
dans le monde c'est le charbon avec à
peu près 40% de l'électricité mondiale
toujours qu'on fixe et les ordres de
grandeur entre 1945 année où certains
d'entre vous étaient déjà vives en est
aujourd'hui
et bien la production électrique
mondiale est passée de 600 térawatts
heure c'est à dire la production
française actuelle à 20000 donc l'accès
massif et démocratique à l'électricité
c'est même pas un fait de la révolution
industrielle c'est un fait de la
deuxième moitié du 20e siècle
c'est extrêmement récent extrêmement
récent et c'est extrêmement facile
les deux tiers de l'électricité mondiale
sont faites avec des combustibles
fossiles charbon 40% gaz 25
merci monsieur le rapporteur
vous aimeriez avoir maintenant la
réponse à vos questions on va dire que
vous avez pris nos questions sous un
certain angle
l'un est la question qui vous viendrez
c'est effectivement nous on peut parler
peut-être un peu du coup puisque vous
avez pris des volumes donc je suppose
que vous voulez en venir que les volumes
vont déterminer le coût pour partie et
pour partie et les politiques qui sont
qui ont qui s'ensuivent alors maintenant
réponse à la première question le
rapport de la cour des comptes sur les
coups je les ai pas lues en totalité
j'ai lu la synthèse et j'ai eu le
plaisir de discuter plusieurs fois avec
michèle pappalardo
moi je trouve que c'est un exercice
extrêmement salutaire qui devrait être
répétée sur les autres formes d'énergie
parce que au moins on sait de quoi on
parle et on a défini les concepts il ya
une deuxième question qui n'a rien à
voir avec la première d'une certaine
manière qui est est ce que ça va devenir
compétitif ça va rester compétitives
d'un point de vue économique ma réponse
est oui même et y compris en tenant
compte du coût des accidents possibles
etc
alors ça peut en choquer certains
d'entre vous des mêmes et y compris en
tenant compte de ça la réponse pour moi
est oui parce que si on commence à tenir
compte des externalités pour le
nucléaire faute en faut faire de même
pour toutes les autres est une
indication entre autres qui répond par
anticipation à la question 6 si vous
mettez un coût de la tonne de co2 à 100
euros vous augmenter le coût de
production de l'électricité au charbon
de 100 euros par mégawattheure
si vous mettez une tonne de co2 à 100
euros
oui si les électriciens doivent payer la
tonne de co2 qu'ils émettent 100 euros
le coût de production d'un mégawatt
heure au charbon est augmentée de 100
euros aussi un mégawatt heure au charbon
il ya une tonne de co2
il est très simple ce qui veut dire que
le consommateur final voit le coût du
kilowattheure électrique augmenté de 10
centimes
si je mets une taxe carbone à 100 euros
la tonne de co2 soit dit en passant dans
un marché européen qui a été créé pour
mettre de la concurrence partout et tout
le temps ce qui à mes yeux est une
ânerie sans nom sur l'électricité et
bien comme le système sa juste part la
magie de la circulation des électrons
qui ne se stocke pas non pas sur le coup
le plus bas mais sur le coup le plus
élevé du dispositif de production
utilisés à tout moment si vous augmentez
200 euros le coût de production sur les
centrales à charbon vous augmenter de
100 euros le mégawattheure le coût de
l'électricité pour tout le monde c'est
ça la magie du marché libéralisé qui
soit dit en passant est une ânerie
cendres pas à cause du coup je suis très
favorable à des hausses de prix de
l'électricité pour engendrer des
économies d'énergie à cause du fait que
c'est une rente qui va là où elle
devrait pas aller c'est plutôt salle la
halle à la question donc j'en reviens
est ce que cette source d'électricité va
rester économique oui alors surtout si
on sait quels sont les trucs qui compte
pour moi quand on se place du point de
vue de la france
il yad'autres qui compte pour moi du
point de vue de la france 3 on va dire 1
l'état de la balance du commerce
extérieur
2 le taux de chômage est trois l'état
des comptes publics
dit autrement le monde sympathique est
un monde dans lequel j'ai pas trop de
chômage
j'ai un commerce extérieur qui est à peu
près équilibré et j'ai un budget qui
partant en vrille
je vais peut être vous choquer mais le
pouvoir d'achat moyen du français n'est
pas mon sujet premier parce que toute
façon je pense qu'il va baisser et que
plus on s'arc boute sur le pouvoir
d'achat du français moyen
et plus on va dégrader les trois autres
indicateurs dont je viens de parler la
grande distribution a fait le bonheur du
consommateur et le malheur de la balance
commerciale est une valeur de l'empereur
français
donc elle a fait le malheur du taux de
chômage et le malheur de la balance
commerciale la subvention à l'énergie
fera le bonheur de l'automobiliste
pendant
court instant et à cause de l'effet
récessif des chocs pétroliers fera
ensuite le bonheur du dhofar ou le
malheur plus exactement du taux de
chômage et celui des comptes publics
donc moi j'ai trois critères qui
comptent pour moi c'est la balance
commerciale le taux de chômage les
comptes publics si je prends ces trois
critères en considération le nucléaire
et la forme d'électricité pour laquelle
l'impact sur la balance commerciale est
le plus faible
alors c'est clair qu'on dépend des
importations d'uranium tout à fait vrai
mais ça représente cacahuètes dans le
prix du kilowattheure final ça peut se
stocker pendant des années donc pendant
des années on attend de se retourner un
peu si le kazakhstan nous fait des
misères on ira voir le canada et si le
canada nous fait des misères on ira voir
l'australie est si l'australie il fait
des misères on ira voir le digère bon en
quelques années on a le temps de se
retourner avec le pétrole on a 3 mois de
stocks on a le temps de rien du tout et
comme ça et avec le gaz c'est pareil
vous l'avez constaté l'hiver dernier il
ya eu une tension sur le gaz à cause de
la hausse de la consommation
d'électricité et de chauffage
les russes et les norvégiens ils font
tout ce qu'ils veulent les norvégiens
sont sympathiques les ruches se pose que
ça va donner dans le dans le temps mais
on est comme ça avec les importations de
gaz
l'espagne qui a dû doubler son parc
éolien un parc de centrales à gaz à peu
près de même puissance qui aujourd'hui
ces deux kilowattheure au gaz à cause de
l'intermittence quand elle fait un
kilowattheure d'éolien elle s'est mise
comme ça avec des importations de gaz
qui dans la situation économique qu'elle
connaît aujourd'hui et sans ces
problèmes en passer donc encore une fois
trois éléments qui compte à mes yeux le
nucléaire danse de ce point de vue est
une très bonne forme d'optimum pour la
production d'électricité de masse et en
fait c'est même la seule qui est
accessible en france parce que
l'hydroélectricité on peut plus noyés
beaucoup de vale l'éolien à cause de son
caractère diffus et intermittents aura
un taux de pénétration qui sera limité
et la biomasse c'est pareil on peut
faire des calculs d'ordre de grandeur on
se rend compte que le potentiel
disponible pour faire de l'électricité
surtout si on veut continuer à pouvoir
manger dans un monde avec moins
d'engrais il n'est pas il est pas si
étendue que ça donc le nucléaire pour
moi c'est très compétitif pour de bonnes
raisons
est-ce qu'il faut prolonger les
centrales nucléaires actuelles
j'ai envie de vous dire je suis content
si ça arrive c'est pas à moi de prendre
la décision ni à vous il ya une autorité
de sûreté dans ce pays qui a été mise
justement pour que le nucléaire ne soit
pas placée sous le fait du prince
c'est à dire l'émotion du politique
laissons laisse les sons l'asn faire son
boulot saleh était fait pour ça et là il
ya quelque chose aussi qui est un pour
moi un point de principe ou bien on
considère qu'il existe une autorité qui
est techniquement compétente pour dire
ce qui peut fonctionner ce qui ne peut
pas fonctionner et on a confiance dans
les gens qui sont là à ce moment où il
allait se faire son boulot ou bien on
n'a pas confiance dans les gens qui sont
là et à ce moment on ferme pas
fessenheim on vire les gens qui sont à
la tête de l'asn moi si j'ai un
collaborateur en qui j'ai pas confiance
je passe pas derrière son dos pour faire
son boulot je le vire bon là c'est
exactement pareil
ou bien la sng fait de gens en les
décalant la confiance et à ce moment on
écoute ses recommandations et c'est un
problème de l'exploitant et de l'asn
il faut savoir que sur les filières
graphite-gaz l'autorité de sûreté qui à
l'époque n'était pas une autorité de
sûreté puisque c'était une direction du
ministère avait dit à et df votre truc
c'est pas terrible
vous allez me faire tel tel talent est
tel type d'aménagement ou vous arrêter
et df arrêté a trouvé que c'était trop
cher arrêtez donc en ce qui concerne les
centrales nucléaires ou bien l'autorité
de sûreté dans laquelle on a confiance
dit voilà ce qu'il faut faire et
l'exploitant choisi s'il trouve que ça
coûte trop cher garrett s'il trouve que
c'est rentable il le fait voilà donc
cessez donc la réponse à la question
encore une fois c'est en tant que
citoyen
si l'asn considère qu'il est légitime de
prolonger les centrales nucléaires je
considère que économiquement c'est une
bonne idée cela étant même si l'asn
considère que c'est pas une bonne idée
de prolonger les centrales nucléaires à
cause de ce que je viens de répondre aux
points
mon sentiment c'est qu'il faut en
construire d'autres à la place parce que
compte tenu des externalités des modes
fossiles encore une fois et des
externalités du mode nucléaire je pense
que le fossile créé beaucoup plus de
risque globalement que le nucléaire est
dans les risques globaux je vous ai pas
parlé du changement climatique
j'ai pas eu le temps de vous exposer en
quoi pour moi le printemps arabe étaient
déjà très largement une conséquence de
la contrainte énergie climat
mais il est évident qu'on va avoir des
déstabilisations socio économique
massive dans un monde dans lequel il ya
à la fois un problème sur l'énergie
fossile et un climat qui se dérèglent
rapidement et ça c'est pas ça sent ça
sent pas bon pour mes enfants ni même
pour moi
donc je préfère de très loin vivre avec
le risque maîtrisé existants mais qu'on
connaît à peu près d'une centrale
nucléaire plutôt que là le risque
totalement non maîtrisée d'un monde qui
devient violent dictatorial et guerrier
parce qu a pas assez de pétrole et que
le climat se met à faire n'importe quoi
et pour avoir bien creuser le sujet
depuis cinq ans je pense que
malheureusement la deuxième éventualité
est loin d'être une vue de l'esprit
troisième question est ce que les tarifs
actuels de l'électricité vous paraissent
fidèlement réfléter le coût réel si on
inclut les externalités fossiles la
réponse est non je vous ai donné tout à
l'heure une information à 100 euros la
tonne de co2 faut que le kilo oued le
consommateur final paye son prix du
kilowattheure 10 centimes plus cher donc
l'électricité et je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure l'énergie ne vaut rien donc je
persiste et signe électricité ne vont
pas assez cher mais c'est pas parce
qu'elle vaut pas assez cher que la
hausse de prix doit arriver avec des
hausses de la facture qu'on paye ou
gaziers et un charbonnier
elle doit arriver par des taxes qui sont
à recyclage national de l'argent qui est
très accessoirement vous paye et paie
une partie de mes clients et permettre
de faire un certain nombre de choses
sans lesquelles on n'a pas les moyens
d'action pour le budget public donc la
question des impôts c'est parce qu'ils
sont bons ou mauvais c'est il en faut de
monde c'est qu'il faut des impôts la
question de choisir les bons pense que
les taxes sur l'énergie sont le très bon
impôt et ça ne fait pas obstacle au fait
que par ailleurs on a intérêt à choisir
les modes de production électrique qui
optimise le taux de chômage va vous la
baisse du taux de chômage la balance
commerciale et l'équilibré des finances
publiques
comment est-ce que ça doit évoluer à mes
yeux je pense qu'il faut mettre un tarif
progressif de l'électricité en place
c'est à dire que plus vous connais pas
du tout à un tarif dégressif dans plus
vous en conserver plus vous payez cher
alors vous allez me dire c'est anti
nataliste antilles etc
on peut très bien tous les gens qui ont
regardé la fiscalité de près savent très
bien que la bonne taxe est une taxe sans
trou dans le fromage pas de niche et
quand vous avez des situations
particulières voulait corriger avec des
mesures particulières pas de niche la
bonne taxe sur l'énergie assiette large
pas de dérogation visibilité c'est ça
les bonnes pâques sur l'énergie quand
vous commencez à mettre des trous dans
fromage partout en disant peut-être que
machin qui a pas les moyens et ses
terrasses et le début de la fin donc si
les gens qui ont trop d'enfants
ou pas assez d'argent pour les enfants
qu'ils ont des problèmes à payer leur
facture électrique c'est un prince qui
se règlent en tant que tel vous pouvez
payer directement une allocation par
enfant au foyer on peut tout imaginer
mais c'est un brent qui se traite en
tant que tel voilà donc ça devrait
augmenter et par ailleurs il faut bien
évidemment remettre en place un système
de taxe carbone alors pour l'électricité
le problème est largement réglé par le
système européen des quotas
mais je pense que le système européen
des quotas devrait être complétée de
deux choses la directive devrait être
d'entrée de jeu prolongé jusqu'à la fin
de vie des centrales électriques
donc on devrait d'entrée de jeu
aujourd'hui donner de la visibilité aux
acteurs économiques jusqu'en 2050 les
acteurs économiques les connaît bien ça
fait 25 ans qui me font vivre
s'ils n'ont pas de visibilité ils font
rien le grand paradoxe c'est que
l'acteur économique ne s'est pas payer
lui-même sa prime d'assurance donc dit
autrement si vous lui donnez pas de
visibilité
il fait pas une espérance mathématiques
de pertes en se disant c'est ça que je
dois faire
il ne fait rien rien donc si vous lui
donnez pas de visibilité sur le prix
auquel il achètera son quota d'ici à
il ne fera rien alors pour ça ça veut
dire deux choses compléter la directive
jusqu'en 2005 un sens à des combats des
français mais ça dépend éventuellement
du lobbying que les français avisés
peuvent faire à bruxelles
donc compléter la directive jusqu'en
2050 émettre dès à présent un prix
croissants annoncé à l'as vence pour les
les quotas mis aux enchères dit
autrement vous dit dès à présent aux
électriciens en 2013 tu paieras ton pote
à 12 en 2014
14 au minimum en 2015 18 au minimum en
22 au minimum etc etc etc jusqu'en 2050
et là les gens ils font quelque chose
tant qu'on est dans un système dans
lequel il n'y a pas de visibilité sur la
contrainte à venir sur des
infrastructures qui dure 50 ans et qui
pour certaines
je pense notamment au nucléaire ils
demandent des immobilisations de
capitaux pendant huit ans avant de
sortir le premier kilowatt heure faut
pas espérer une seule seconde que des
acteurs financiarisé parce que c'est le
cas de la quasi-totalité des producteurs
d'électricité sur le vieux continent
vont faire des choses intelligentes à
l'avant ce n'est pas une seconde vers la
financiarisation a tellement raccourci
les échéances temporel et là aussi
l'idée bruxelles que en mettant les
acteurs dans le marché avec des
actionnaires
dont on sait pas où ils sont le truc
aller mieux se porter c'est une vue de
l'esprit
cependant beaucoup plus mal on peut pas
piloter des infrastructures à 50 ans de
manière commode dans ce genre de
contexte
donc le don qu'il faut mettre le seul
moyen de corriger un peu pas le système
c'est de mettre en place des quotas
keith donc pour lequel le prix minimum
d'enchères est annoncé à l'as vence avec
40 ans de préavis ça n'interdit pas de
module est ensuite le rythme
d'augmentation
si on se rend compte que c'est trop dur
on peut abaisser un peu si on se rend
compte que les gens c'est trop facile on
peut monter un peu mais il faut donner
de la visibilité à l'avant ce vraiment
le maître mot dans le monde économique
c'est visibilité si le cadre fiscal
change tous les quatre matins vous êtes
à peu près sûr de ne pas obtenir quelque
chose de sympathique
oui c'est pour ça que je disais c'est
une recommandation pour un lobbying
actif de la france au niveau européen et
l'allemagne dit à la fois je veux sauver
le climat puisqu'elle a un plan très
ambitieux et je veux sortir du nucléaire
très bien on lui colle des quotas très
cher et si elle s'en sort avec ça il ya
des problèmes pas tous moi ça me pose
aucun problème
voilà les mécanismes de soutien aux
énergies renouvelables je vous ai
répondu je pense que ils sont gérés en
dépit du bon sens ce qu'il faudrait
faire c'est mettre une mesures
transversales que je suis justement les
présenter à la cour des comptes ya pas
longtemps que j'appelle le coût à la
tonne de co2 évitée en le coût à la
tonne de co2 évitée c'est quoi ces jeux
prend aujourd'hui une mesure dont
l'effet escompté et d' éviter d'émettre
du co2 et très accessoirement d'éviter
d'importer des combustibles fossiles
sept défis cette mesure va déformer
l'avenir alors je peux prendre une
mesure qui est une prime à la casse sur
des voitures qui consomment peu ou sur
l'installation d'éoliennes peu importe
je prends une mesure et je compare
l'avenir du monde avec et sans mesure à
la fois pour l'équation économique
d'ensemble et pour les émissions de co2
d'ensemble ensuite fait le rapport entre
les deux et ça me donne mon coût à la
tonne de co2 évitée alors une petite
indication si vous faites du panneau
photovoltaïque produit en france le coût
à la tonne de co2 évitée lors de dix
mille euros devait payer dix mille euros
d'argent public pour éviter une tonne de
co2 si vous faites des panneaux produits
en chine
il est négatif dit autrement vous
subventionnez la hausse des émissions de
co2 parce que le temps de retour sur
carbone d'un panneau fabriqué en chine a
de l'électricité au charbon chinoises
est de l'ordre de 30 ans ce qui est
supérieure à la durée de vie du panneau
il faut de l'ordre de 30 ans vous allez
fabriquer votre panneau en chine avec de
l'électricité à huit ou neuf cents
grammes de co2 par kilowattheure est en
france vous allez déplacé de
l'électricité de réseau françaises qui
est en gros à 130 ou 140 g de co2 par
kilowattheure donc en gros pour un
kilowattheure d'électricité chinois à ce
que vous utilisez pour fabriquer le
panneau il faut que vous en récupériez 6
à 8
une fois que le panneau est installée en
france il se trouve que la quantité de
kilowattheures nécessaire pour faire le
panneau est de l'ordre de 3 ans de
fonctionnement du panneau donc si vous
devez récupérer en l'occurrence est
plutôt 8 8 fois plus d'électricité en
france que ce que vous avez consommé en
chine ça veut dire que 3 fois 8 24 vous
êtes à 25 et plus vous mettez le système
autour vous êtes à 30 donc il faut 30
ans de fonctionnement d'un panneau
fabriqué en chine pour équilibrer son
carbone de fabrication en évitant
d'électricité française
donc quand on à subventionner
l'installation du photovoltaïque en
france je reviens à mes critères
essentiels on a subventionné un
déséquilibre commercial pas d'emplois en
france et une hausse des émissions de
co2 donc on a tout faux et un
déséquilibre des finances publiques tout
faux sur toute la ligne et je suis écolo
je suis soucieux de préserver un monde
stable pour mes enfants c'est ça pour
moi la définition de l'écologie c'est
préserver un environnement stable dans
lequel les enfants pourront être mené
une vie à peu près sympathique
donc il ya encore des ressources
biologiques qu'il ya encore un climat à
peu près stable et qui encore des
sources d'énergie qu'on puisse utiliser
et le monde a toujours été avec des
risques il l'était avant il le sera
demain
l'idée qu'on va supprimer tous les
risques partout et tout le temps est une
vue de l'esprit
il faut choisir les bons mais on va
jamais les supprimer partout et tout le
temps donc le donc voilà donc par contre
il ya des trucs qu'aujourd'hui on
pourrait faire qui serait extrêmement
efficace mais c'est un peu moins
allez je vais vous taquiner un peu c'est
un peu moins démago monter le prix de
l'essence va un coût à la tonne de co2
évitée extrêmement intéressant
extrêmement intéressant ça allège la
balance commerciale 70 milliards d'euros
de déficit l'année dernière ça crée de
l'emploi en france et ça équilibre des
finances publiques
excellente musulmans sauf que ça oblige
à dire aux français
le genre de choses pas sympathique que
je viens de vous évoquez soit dit en
passant
parce que vous allez devoir gérer un
certain nombre de transition vous allez
devoir gérer une transition sur
l'urbanisme
parce que le système urbanistes 20
l'urbanisme actuel ne résiste pas à une
forte contrainte sur l'approvisionnement
pétrolier vous allez sortir une partie
des gens qui sont aujourd'hui dans les
franges périurbaines du jeu économique
ils seront hors du jeu économique dont
vous allez [ __ ] au chômage
essentiellement et ça a déjà commencé et
voyez bien que les poches de chômage
apparaissent dans l'est dans les zones
périurbaines des devils par petites
touches pour le moment ça va augmenter
vous allez avoir besoin de remplacer les
voitures actuelles par des voitures plus
petit parce qu'à mon avis la mesure la
plus efficace dans les 30 ans qui
viennent c'est pas de passer à la
voiture électrique c'est de remplacer
des voitures à 6 litres aux 100 en
parler de chevaux nouveaux modèles donc
le truc qui plafonne à 110 qui fait 30
chevaux de puissance de moteur qui pèse
500 kg et qui consomme en un litre et
demi au sens
nos ingénieurs seront très bien faire
sans votre problème et si vous demandez
à renault et peugeot de faire ce genre
de truc en plus vous sauver l'emploi
parce que s'ils font pas ça ils font
faillite confère ce qui s'est passé pour
general motors qui ne savaient faire que
des voitures à 10 ou 15 litres au cent
quand le prix du pétrole est monté là où
il est monté en 2008
donc là tu es là pays ppa sauver
l'industrie automobile française et
d'une manière générale
enfin il faut le dire quand même ati ppa
sauver l'industrie automobile française
en forçant pendant cinquante ans les
constructeurs automobiles à faire des
petits moteurs et en amortissant les
variations de prix de marché par des
taxes qui dépendent des volumes et par
des prix hors taxe on a considérablement
stabilisés le système considérablement
donc quand je dis il faut monter le prix
de l'électricité
c'est pas pour faire de la peine aux
consommateurs c'est pour forcer le
français qui n'en peut mais à payer la
prime d'assurance qui va lui permettre
de stabiliser le pays
c'est ça le but du jeu c'est pas de
faire souffrir le consommateur pour le
plaisir pas le but du jeu but du jeu
c'est stabiliser le pays
je crois qu'on sera tous d'accord autour
de cette danse est enceinte pour
considérer qu'un pays qui n'est pas en
paix est un pays où la prospérité
difficile à trouver et ce genre de
risque laissés à eux mêmes
c'est riche de potentialités de conflit
y compris chez nous et alors ça peut ne
pas être des conflits extérieurs ça peut
être des conflits intérieurs des guerres
civiles
des lots de partout et enfin voilà tout
ça et peu sympathique globalement voilà
donc mal ciblés oui on devrait avoir une
étude préalable du coût à la tonne de
co2 évitée
dès qu'on prend la moindre mesure
budgétaire destiné à faire baisser les
émissions de co2 je dis pas qu'il faut
pas en prendre
je dis qu'il faut faire cette analyse
préalable pour moi c'est absolument
indispensable
enfin est-ce que le prix d'électricité
en europe devrait mieux refléter le coût
des émissions de ges je crois je voulais
rentrer répondu un certain nombre de
fois que la réponse est oui
vingt-cinq fois oui ce qui à mon avis
redevient un combat aujourd'hui c'est de
ne pas créer d'incohérence entre le fait
que les pays sont libres de choisir leur
politique d'investissement électrique et
que l'europe a l'obligation de
répercuter les variations de coûts qui
en résultent à l'ensemble de la plaque
européenne
dit autrement si les allemands prennent
un choix qui augmente le prix de
l'électricité chez eux par le jeu du
système qui a été mis en place tous les
états périphériques on paye le coût le
le coup voilà
et ça je considère ce n'est pas normal
donc ou bien on fait la politique tous
ensembles et à ce moment tout le monde
partage les coûts ça serait probablement
mon premier choix ou bien chacun reste
libre de faire la politique qui veut
dans son coin et à ce moment chacun en
assument les coûts et donc ya pas
d'interconnexion aux frontières pour
permettre aux allemands d'importer de
l'électricité ailleurs quand il décide
de supprimer leurs centrales nucléaires
un principe de responsabilisation des
états donc encore une fois si on leur
laisse une marge de manoeuvre
ils doivent en assumer la responsabilité
s'ils ne veulent pas en assumer la
responsabilité ont l'habitude à lise et
à ce moment on va vers plus de
fédéralisme encore une fois ce n'est
probablement pas la plus vraie option
dans le monde dans lequel on sera
plongée mais c'est un choix c'est un
choix
voilà je merci est-ce que je vous
félicite jeu sincèrement je ne serai pas
très bien où est ce que vous alliez en
partant ou du moins où est ce que vous
vouliez nous emmener en partant et vous
avez bien mener votre
alors on est votre scénario une question
que vous n'avez pas posée mais qui est
implicite dans ce que je vous ai raconté
c'est que je pense que le coût d'accès
au capital privé va considérablement se
devenir considérable en plus difficile
parce que dans un monde qui connaîtra
une récession tous les trois ans c'est
évident que l'accès au capital va
devenir plus difficile
ce qui veut dire que je suis en train de
vous dire en creux que une forme de
renationalisation des systèmes
électriques et probablement pas la plus
mauvaise idée qu'on puisse avoir
est-ce que vous avez des questions
complémentaires ou es ce que vous avez
eu des réponses intéressantes aux
questions que vous vous posez les uns et
les autres sur le rapporteur et
effectivement on peut pas dire que le
discours de que vous avez retenu est
celui qu'ont entendu jusqu'à maintenant
donc le pas des portes qui vous ai fait
venir
l'augmentation du prix de l'électricité
donc et vous dites faut réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sous
peine d'entraînement d'un changement
climatique va nous conduire à une
récession importante et en termes de
développement de l'énergie
donc c'est réduire la dépendance au
pétrole par les économies d'énergie joue
essentiellement dans un premier temps
oui ensuite l'efficacité énergétique
aussi alors il ya un bon mix des deux
affaires je vais vous prendre un exemple
dans le bâtiment
on a fait des calculs pour aider f que
je suis autorisé à vous donner puisque
ils veulent bien qu'on les publie
l'optimum économique dans le bâtiment
n'est pas de ramener la consommation
d'énergie primaire à 50 kilowattheures
par mètre carré et par an il est plutôt
de l'amener aux alentours de 100
électrifié dit autrement l'optimum
économique de cette affaire c'est pour
sortir le gaz et le fioul de chauffage
qui compte tenu de ce que je vous ai dit
sont pour moi les deux premières
priorités vous isolez mais sans excès
donc vous amener à 80 100 kilowatts
heure de par mètre carré et par an ce
qui est déjà une jolie performance pour
un certain nombre de bâtiments mon avis
dans l'ancien c'est pas si facile que ça
et par ailleurs vous passez le système à
l'électricité alors ça vous empêche pas
d'être intelligent vous pouvez très bien
le passé aux pompes à chaleur 1
mais vous le passez à l'électricité est
bien quand vous faites l'ensemble de ces
d'autres trucs là vous obtenez une
division très forte des émissions par
six à huit dans le bâtiment vous
diminuer l'importation des pays
pétroliers et gaziers c'est excellent
pour l'emploi puisque vous allez devoir
employer des tas de maçon et c'est donc
le vrai sujet c'est que vos enfants il
est bien au lieu de leur dire mon coco
tu vas faire une maîtrise et ensuite tu
seras dans un bureau on leur dise tu vas
aller chercher sur un chantier donc ça
c'est le vrai défi de cette affaire et
c'est le principal
parce qu'aujourd'hui le discours ambiant
on n'est pas du tout celui là mais bon
c'est un vrai défi bien mais par contre
c'est très cohérent est ce que je vous
ai raconté dans un monde à l'énergie
plus rares on va pas être tous dans un
bureau il y aura de plus en plus de gens
qui vont se remettre à transpirer
je peux faire bien ou mal mais c'est
comme ça que les choses vont se passer
donc pour en revenir à ce que gisait là
vous avez un exemple dans lequel un mix
entre les économies c'est à dire
l'isolation et l'électrification avec
évidemment une électricité sans co2 et
pour moi le bon arbitrage
et vous dites ensuite l'on vous dit que
le nucléaire n'est pas opposé à je pense
même encore une fois je suis tout à fait
pour je suis tout à fait pour abl et
vous avez de vie pour le renouvelable
attention à l'heure ce que je dis pour
les renouvelables c'est qu'elle se
valent pas toutes
donc il faut être sélectif avec un
critère de bonne gestion dit autrement
si vous êtes intimement persuadé que
justement la contrainte va nous mettre
dans une situation de finances
difficiles
c'est là que vous devez faire
particulièrement attention à
l'efficacité de la dépense budgétaire
donc mettre des poêles à bois dans les
maisons de campagne après les avoir
isolé
excellente idée énergies renouvelables m
des chauffe eau solaires pour faire de
l'eau chaude
excellente idée énergies renouvelables
mettre des panneaux photovoltaïques
partout dans le pays c'est une idée
complètement idiote donc il faut pas
avoir l'idolâtrie des renouvelables pour
les renouvelables
il faut être sélectif dans ce qu'on fait
et comprendre pourquoi on le fait c'est
ça qui est en train de dire que vous
êtes pour un renouvelables de proximité
où ça dépend pour l'électricité ça n'a
pas de sens parce que le réseau celle
inverse
par contre pour la chaleur oui alors
après on pourrait même faire des trucs
un peu subtile ça dépend on peut très
bien le faire chez nous si on accepte de
payer plus cher à bas après c'est une
affaire de choix c'est ce que disait
tout à l'heure le malheur du
consommateur fait le bonheur du salarié
et inversement
on avait une très bonne démonstration
tout à l'heure sur quand on subventionne
le photovoltaïque on favorise le déficit
commercial
l'un l'emploi en chine et pas en france
et ce2 ce1 vaut aussi pour le panneau
solaire chauffe-eau alors le panneau
solaire chauffe-eau ça dépend du système
d'incitation vous mettez en place
même sur le pv vous vous rendez compte
que le système poser des prix là il a
une variation d'un facteur 3 en fonction
des pays alors nous on est un pays de
profiteurs dont il ya des effets
d'aubaine qui sont absolument monstrueux
dans tous les sens
après encore une fois ça dépend quelle
est la part c'est une manière
d'organiser ce système voilà si vous et
que vous importez moins cher de panne de
chauffe-eau solaire de chine que vous
importez de gaz aujourd'hui pour le
chauffage au gaz qui permet d'avoir
l'eau chaude sanitaire c'est quand même
une bonne affaire donc moi je suis pas
en train de vous dire je sais dès à
présent vous faire la liste exhaustive
complète régionaliser parce que ça va
dépendre aussi des endroits etc
par contre je sais vous décrire la
méthode qui vous permet d'avoir la
réponse en fonction de la zone
géographique dans laquelle vous vous
posez la question et de ce que vous avez
envie de faire bien m'écouter merci
c'est moi j'ai bien aimé votre
démonstration
c'était pas ce sujet mais que dans
domaine du transport vous est pas là on
nous faisait pas titiller un peu plus
pour avoir également vos vos idées en
matière de petites voitures à vue font
monter le prix et dans le même temps
planter des banderilles dans le dos des
constructeurs pour qu'ils descendent des
consommations moyennes
je vais vous livrer un calcul d'ordre de
grandeur qui va peut-être vous
intéressez vous avez probablement
entendu parler du grand paris le coût
d'investissement des infrastructures du
grand paris avant le fameux facteur pis
vous savez entre le budget et le
courriel une fois que le truc est
terminée rigole parce que l'autre jour
j'ai entendu duflot à la radio dire est
ce que vous connaissez un autre truc que
le p r pour lequel le coup double en
cours de route et c'est dommage que j'ai
pas été à côté d'elle parce que j'ai eu
envie de lui dire tout prototype
industriel
le facteur pis il est valable absolument
partout et c'est vrai aussi dans les
développements de logiciels fameux
facteur qui vous avez entre le truc qui
fait papa maman qu'on vous vend pour
cent qui finira par coûter 300 à
l'arrivée j'ai mal absolument partout
donc
pour revenir à la question posée dans le
domaine des transports donc le grand
paris à peu près 60 milliards d'euros
nos calculs c'est que ça va déplacer de
l'ordre de 2 à 3 % de la mobilité
motorisée des franciliens explications
explications ou bien vous mettez les
lignes de transports en commun dans des
zones denses où déjà très peu de gens
utilisent leur voiture
les gens marchent utilisent le bus
utilisent le métro etc dont vous allez
avoir essentiellement du report modal en
provenance de gens qui ne se déplace pas
en voiture plus de l'induction de trafic
l'induction de trafic c'est moins chez
moi j'avais l'intention de rester chez
moi puisque le métro passant présent en
bas de chez moi je le prends et je me
baladais ailleurs et bien le vrai report
modal en provenance de la voiture il est
marginal dans cette histoire ou bien
vous mettez en zones peu denses
vous faites une station de métro au
mieux de la pampa c'est-à-dire au
plateau de saclay et à ce moment comme
la zone d'attraction de la gare est de 1
à 2 kilomètres si vous êtes en zones peu
denses vous attirez personnes et donc
personne avec une voiture enfin les gens
ont tous une voiture mais il en a tiré
pas beaucoup ils vont directement lieu
voilà et soit dit en passant la
construction des stations de métro dans
la pampa c'est-à-dire à saclay va
commencer par produire un premier effet
qui est que dès qu'on saura que la
station de métro va se construire ont
construit à côté pour héberger des gens
qui habiteront à perpète parce que à ce
moment là il y aura pas le métro et
viendront en voiture
et le jour où il y aura le métro ils
déménageront pas de père pète de la wii
sont pour aller se mettre ailleurs donc
vous aurez mis les gens dans un squeeze
dans un corner dont ils ne sortiront pas
parce que le métro arrive ce truc là et
tu es tf1 jeudi a été une très bonne
idée en 1940 probablement pour en 1930
aujourd'hui c'est totalement
anachronique les trucs en petite
couronne sont intelligents les trucs en
grande couronne c'est du délire complet
pardonnez moi d'utiliser cette
expression mais c'est pas du tout en
phase avec les enjeux auxquels on va
devoir faire face par du tout donc pour
en revenir à ce que c'est du gaspillage
d'argent public total pour en revenir à
ce que je disais sur les transports dont
60 milliards
le grand paris 2 à 3% de la mobilité
motorisée je reprends l'exemple de mes
voitures qui consomment pas beaucoup
donc je commence par planter des
banderilles dans le dos de renault et de
peugeot ils me sortent mes deux chevaux
et là je vais une prime à la casse sur
la totalité du prix d'achat de la
voiture pour tous les ménages
franciliens qui mettent à la casse leur
voiture à 6 litres aux cent pour
m'acheter ma voiture à un litre et demi
il ya 6 millions de voitures en ile de
france
france 6 billions fois 10060 milliard
dans le premier cas de figure
j'ai changé la vie de trois pour cent
des gens qui consomment qui utilise une
voiture dans le deuxième cas de figure
j'ai changé la vie de tous les gens qui
utilisent une voiture pour la même somme
d'argent public la même et si vous
voulez pas dans le même temps que la tpp
se casse la figure parce que vous allez
consommer quatre fois moins de carburant
vous multipliez le prix de l'essence par
trois cqfd c'est exactement ce que je
vous dit leur donc c'est ça donc voilà
un exemple de mesure dans laquelle vous
avez résolu le problème à urbanisme
constant parce que c'est pas en disant
que vous allez faire déménager de
banlieue lointaine tous les gens qui
n'auront plus rien à y faire dans 50
pour ça il vous faut 50 à 100 tant en
version sympathique sinon vous des
portes et tout le monde sait pas
sympathique donc en version sympathique
pour modifier la forme des villes faut
50 à 100 ans
et pour répondre à la contrainte
pétrolières qui commence à s'exercer
aujourd'hui et qui va devenir
particulièrement mordante dans les 10 à
20 à 15 ans qui viennent
vous n'avez pas d'autre choix que de
baisser très très vite à technologie
constante parce que le seul truc qu'on
sait faire facilement aujourd'hui c'est
les voitures à pétrole
la consommation unitaire des véhicules
et à ce compte là vous sauver vous
sauvez la stabilité dans une bonne
partie de la couronne francilienne
merci beaucoup je remercie t as tu
voulais une question pratique je vous ai
trouvé très sévères vis-à-vis de
l'intermittence des éoliennes
alors parce que j'en ai deux cents et
quelques dans mon département qui est un
département rural et où il ya encore
quelques installations qui vont se faire
je le traverse quasiment trois ou quatre
fois par semaine avec une voiture
derrière qui ne peut pas consommer un
litre et demi au sens et je les vois
rarement à l'arrêt alors est ce que je
je passe à des horaires où elle tourne
systématiquement parce qu'elles m'ont vu
arriver ou bien un élément de réponse
ces chiffres officiels je vais vous
donner un élément de réponse
d'abord comme vous le savez la
production injectée sur le réseau et une
fonction de la du cube de la vitesse
donc entre une vitesse de rotation
données et deux fois la vitesse de
rotation donné la puissance injectée sur
le réseau varient d'un facteur 8 puis si
ça tourne deux fois plus vite ces huit
fois plus d'électricité sur le réseau
peuvent donc cesser le culte de la
vitesse du vent docsis et ça c'est un
truc qu'on a du mal à apprécier avec nos
sens et la deuxième réponse si van
marnais est moins intéressant que le
grand vide et et les besoins non mais
alors effectivement mais ça il faudrait
qu'on le fasse passer au niveau du grand
public parce que on est toujours pareil
on est dans la logique du tout ou rien
soit le tournoi elle tombe pas mais
effectivement c'est tournent pas vite
il ya le fameux facteur de 2010 piqué
voilà un début de réponse à votre
question il ya des physiciens qui été
gratté par cette question qui ont là au
terme d'un long travail de fourmi parce
qu'il n'ya pas de centralisation de ce
genre d'info été récupéré les puissances
injectée sur le réseau auprès de rte
qu'il fournit pour la france de
l'exploitant allemand caf un deuil du
réseau allemand qui fournit pour
l'allemagne en plus en plusieurs
morceaux de l'exploitant espagnol qui
fournissent à pour l'espagne un jour par
jour donc il faut faire un travail
extrêmement passionnant de recopie des
trucs dans un fichier excel et voilà ce
que ça donne
entre septembre 2010 et mars 2011 avec
un pad temps qui est celui de leur si ma
mémoire est bonne
donc vous voyez que en gros ou bien vous
avez une dépression atlantique et toutes
les éoliennes produisent qu'elle soit en
espagne en allemagne en france en uk etc
ou bien vous êtes en régime
anticyclonique et vous avez un peu de
vent résiduelles à gibraltar dans le
couloir rhodanien et cetera mais vous
avez un talon et la puissance installée
là haut
donc ce que vous disent graphique c'est
que en moyenne vous n'êtes sur ces six
mois vous n'êtes jamais à mieux que la
moitié de la puissance installée que la
puissance garantie est une petite
fraction de la puissance installée de
l'ordre de quelques pourcents et vous
voyez ici clairement l'intermittence
induites que vous devez contrebalancée
par soit des barrages soient des
centrales à gaz
alors les espagnols ont choisi des
centrales à gaz ge qui maintenant leur
route
en gaz et en co2 donc en même temps
qu'ils installaient 15 mégawatts
d'éolien ils ont installé par dont 20
gigawatts d'éolien ils ont installé 15
mégawatts de centrales à gaz et ils
publient les très beaux communiqué de
presse compte c'est les ollières qui
domine mais enfin il devrait publier
trois fois plus souvent des communiqués
de presse en expliquant que c'est le gaz
qui domine un ba oui exactement ça
qu'ils devraient faire
les allemands ont choisi de compenser ça
avec le charbon et les danois ils ont
fait un truc qui est absolument génial
comme en gros le pays est trop petit
compte tenu de la quantité d'éoliennes
qui là pour absorber sa propre
électricité d'origine éolienne
quand le vent souffle il exporte vers
qui est ce qu'ils exportent vers les
pays avec lesquels il est interconnecté
l'allemagne d'une part et la norvège de
l'autre quand la norvège reçoit de
l'électricité danoise que le le danois
ne peut pas fuir il doit s'en
débarrasser c'est pour l'équilibré du
réseau électrique doit absolument s'en
débarrasser que fait danemark à ce
moment il est prêt à vendre à n'importe
quel prix quel est le prix auquel de la
norvège va accepter l'électricité
danoise le coût de production marginale
d'un barrage on sait le coût de
production n'a rien d'un barrage c'est
les 3 minutes d'ouvriers qui sont
nécessaires à ouvrir et fermer le
robinet c'est 0-0
donc les danois ont subventionné avec
leur argent a eu une industrie qui va
vendre à l'exportation à un coût
marginal nul et quant à eux ils ont
besoin d'électricité parce qu'il n'y a
pas de vent il importe en provenance du
producteur norvégien qui pend fout là
pour le coup leur fait payer le prix
fort puisque c'est l'électricité de
pointe donc le danemark a bâti affaire
minable et c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu la
bronca au danemark sur ses subventions à
l'éolien qui ont été abandonnés depuis
tout simplement parce que ça revient à
subventionner le danois le producteur
norvégien qui possède les barrages
voilà donc les norvégiens sont ravis et
ils sont tout à fait pour l'électricité
d'origine éolienne tout comme du reste
les vendeurs de gaz si vous faites venir
ici un vendeur de gaz il va vous
expliquer de l'éolien et c'est
absolument génial
- copenhague j'étais allé au meeting de
l'international gaccio l'yonne où tous
comme des tous en choeur j'étais le seul
français dans la salle je crois et il
n'y avait pas un journaliste dans la
salle et tout son coeur
les gaziers disait l'éolien c'est génial
l'éolien assez génial les voilà tous en
choeur bien merci beaucoup
s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions merci
pour votre
prestations non merci pour être venu à
notre invitation et bravo pour votre
prestation
eh bien bon travaux je vous ans et avoue
que j'en vois le la présentation